[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
stream salut Laurent
salut Stéphane et bonjour à tous ravi de
retrouver tout le monde pour et bien
d'abord la petite finale la troisième
place et ensuite la grande finale avec
les gothams face au
Tiger's de Shanghai mais pour l'instant
on a un match
indiano indien
en tout cas deux équipes indiennes qui
ont pas démérités qui se retrouvent on
se retrouve quand même à jouer pour la
troisième place donc les yogis contre la
team MGD 1 et avec un changement c'est
ça on peut changer les équipes et on
voit tout de suite un changement avec
Arica qui a été remplacé ça qui a été en
petite forme hier à Rica
et vidite
donc qui joue est-ce qu'il a joué hier
vite je crois pas
il a pas joué hier ils ont perdu hier
les yogis
je suis certain ça non plus ils avaient
une équipe complètement différente
[Musique]
entre
Savita et et
à Rica pardon pardon ouais il y avait
donc il y avait pas visite mais il y
avait ça effectivement
c'est sûr qu'il y avait Sarine
c'est incroyable la mémoire
pas très impressionnant
en tout cas c'est aussi la compo qu'ils
avaient contre
contre Cannes contre will stream
effectivement oui parce que Étienne
Macron a
fait un truc bizarre il a battu il a
battu Sarine et visite il a perdu qu'on
est deux moins fort donc vai et pranesh
donc c'était un peu un peu étrange comme
tournoi
comme match alors on a une petite
française elle joue elle joue quelque
chose de très solide pas ça vite bah
écoute pourquoi pas elle a pas
complètement tort parce que
effectivement c'est là où visite va
essayer de marquer un point alors en
jouant solide c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal parce que ça va forcer
forcément vite à prendre des risques et
cette position elle est quand même très
sèche voilà on met une tour en D1 c'est
très facile à jouer peut-être l'autre
tour en
haut et bon ben voilà ça ça joue
normalement sur fosse sept peut-être on
va essayer de recycler le cavalier en D4
peut-être et c'est de mettre un E5 les
F3 qui va aller au 5
donc il y a plein de petites idées
peut-être tout d'abord ici et ensuite
cavalier F3
c'est un peu dommage d'avoir le fond en
V3 voilà c'est la seule mauvaise pièce
entre guillemets en V3 qui bute sur le
puron 6 on aime préférer la voir un F3
pour qu'il fasse pression sur le la dame
noire
et c'est pour ça probablement d'ailleurs
c'est exactement pour cette raison que
les Noirs ont égalisé dans cette
position
[Musique]
et après deux joueurs Souilly et
Louis pink avoir évidemment sous réserve
qu'ils aient mis la même compo
mais clairement une équipe qui nous qui
depuis le départ nous nous surprend on
fait des bons résultats
donc
on verra
alors full G5 alors ça commence une par
une c'est ça les parties
si tu veux alors si on va voir la partie
chalet
très dangereuse et Chali et je vais voir
ça on va vérifier ta dextérité à la au
changement de caméra ah mais c'est pas
mal bravo ah bah oui c'est parfait
gros papa saut du jungsi salut à tous
Bienvenue salut
gros papa 21 ça c'est du pseudo ça
c'est
donc tourbéon ouais on va faire B4
normal bon là vraiment il fait à 5 pour
empêcher empêcher B4 Hannibal bon elle a
séché enceinte contre adibad parce que
il peut
il peut quand même il est un peu alors
style très intéressant mais il laisse
des chances ça c'est sûr
elle est hyper tactique et elle est très
dangereuse on l'a vu même contre contre
Blitz la gaine battue et timbacro et
puis encore hier elle a fait enfin la
bâtir du tout dans le match donc
franchement
intéressant
clairement et il joue il prend le centre
là il décide de faire des 5 ça a l'air
complètement ok pour les pour les Noirs
faudrait essayer d'ouvrir la colonne B
alors forcer un cahier de français 3
mais est-ce qu'on peut vraiment
réussir à forcer un cahier prend ses
trois je pense pas
le problème c'est que je vais reculer
je pensais à kg 5 mais ouais
ça force rien du tout parce que j'ai 5
je peux jouer aussi par exemple et tu as
rien forcé du tout donc peut-être c'est
ça certainement le plan de la dybal
alors
dans l'idée empêcher d'empêcher ça
comme ça
[Musique]
ah ouais ça tu alors je suis jamais sûr
sur ces trucs là
c'est toujours c'est souvent un double
tranchant comme tu l'as expliqué est-ce
qu'il faut provoquer H6 ou pas j'en sais
rien là franchement
il y a plus que tu vois
pour commencer
mais c'est avec ta dame c'est un
mesdames c'est vrai est-ce que c'est
vraiment un gros truc le far wash 7 et
quoi est-ce que la dernière est
particulièrement bien placé je pense pas
cette position là toujours si tu veux
qu'on voit un peu la partie la partie
Savita on y était ça à la partie de
pranet peut-être contre regazzi
salut à toi
ma like kill 87
pour ces pseudos twitch tu fais à
diminutif à tout le monde c'est pas mal
[Musique]
il est très souvent sur mon chat
d'accord
et la roi des cèdes dernier coup de Éric
guesis direct
standard dans la française dans la
française on a très souvent un roi qui
se balade
d'un côté je dis pourquoi pas parce
qu'après petit rock on a tellement envie
de d'attaquer sur la loi de l'autre côté
bon
C8 c'est aussi l'idée je pense non mais
le cavalier en racis c'est pas comment
comment il va se mettre en jeu
donc écoute j'aime beaucoup la position
de blanc quoi
c'est ça la grande question
et apparemment d'après ce que dit la
jauge
il a l'air de perdre le pion
e sont pas très bonnes en fait
ce que je peux faire je peux faire tu me
fais ouais 3 4 mais tu vas faire C3 et
ok j'ai pas trop par contre j'ai
peut-être l'idée de faire tout H3 et en
fait je fais coulisser ma tour non
seulement je menace
pour C3 mais aussi et tour à trois et je
me laisse tourgé trois aussi et tourgé
trois ça peut être évident pour protéger
ton pion t'es obligé de venir le caler
F5
5 et H6 c'est bon affaibli en fait le
plan de 7 aussi donc
ouais ça fait jouer tout le monde
c'est typique hein
[Musique]
etc
qui sont pas évident à trouver et c'est
l'idée on en reparlé hier de pousser ses
pions H&A c'est maintenant une façon
aussi évidemment c'est pas simplement
une agression
primaire c'est aussi une façon de
développer sa tour plus tard donc il
faut il faut garder à l'esprit quand on
a poussé le pion h ou puis on a en
l'occurrence il a aucun des deux notre
ami Pradesh et bien de faire coulisser
la tour et voilà voilà on voit qu'il y a
quand même une grosse faiblesse en G7
parce que ce pion n'a pas envie de le
toucher avec les Noirs parce que le pion
H6 peut être très faible et voyez on a
le footcas noir on a le foot casse noire
elle est noir l'ont pas donc
clairement ce pion peut être
peut être attaqué facilement donc là je
m'attends vraiment ce coup de tour H3
quoique aussi en fait on a le temps
aussi parce que ce cavalier en V8 comme
tu l'as dit
ce cavalier en 6 tu vois parce que tu
pensais à faire assise pour libérer et
en fait c'est qu'elle est en B8 mais en
fait si tu fais A6 ça l'aide pas du tout
ça c'est intéressant en même temps tu tu
disais je peux peut-être faire assise
pour le pour libérer et puis tu t'es dit
non non en fait si ça marche pas parce
que tu me laisserais le problème
il faudrait que je
en arrivant ici j'ai pas de cases
peut-être tu répondais M6 mais bon tout
est un peu faible en fait et assise
c'est vrai que le rêve des Noirs genre
raciste pour sortir ce cavalier mais ça
va pas arriver hein parce qu'il y a pas
arrivé peut-être mais même jouer
ASSISTANCE c'est pas du coup et ça porte
trois coups pour juste essayer de faire
un truc et en plus moi en deux couches
je peux refaire la même je te renvoie la
balle le cavalier il est quand même très
mal placé ici en Belgique c'est un gros
problème c'est quoi qu'on puisse dire il
y a aucune case et même s'ils sont en D7
qui est pas déjà gagné et ben il a
toujours qu'une casse ouais fuite enfin
quelque chose de pastel salut Mickaël
1987 et scalaire 36 salut à tous
bienvenue
alors sur un petit peu ce qui se passe
chez tip tayan et
Sarine vas-y
parce que tu partages ton écran je sais
que tu prépares c'est bravo incroyable
quand tu as fait aussi vite incroyable
bravo
c'est dommage que ça arrive et les
blancs
désolé c'était trop tentant là c'était
trop étroit encore
ouais match effectivement pour la
troisième place cette petite fille il y
a des prix c'est quoi les prix
d'ailleurs
est-ce que tu as
est-ce que tu as ça sous la main ou pas
c'est tellement toi de les avoir
je crois que c'est 100 000 à l'équipe
vainqueur donc à partager évidemment
alors après ça dépend je sais pas
comment ça marche mais ok j'ai pas de
accès aux
prières alors c'est marqué je vais
regarder ça tout de suite les infos et
dans les infos on va voir les prix donc
les prix et regardez alors éliminer en
quart de finale
c'est quand même
7500 dollars donc à partager bon c'est
pas
c'est pas mal quand même c'est pas mal
en quatre joueurs s'il est simplement
quatre joueurs en jouet quatrième c'est
10000 dollars 100000 je vais être
enflammé
4e c'est 10000 dollars troisième c'est
15000 deuxième c'est 20 000 et premier
c'est 25000 à partager en quatre ou cinq
joueurs c'est quand même
assez assez conséquent c'est qu'on est
habitué à des
à des prix assez incroyables
donc pas mal
qui mélange un peu des grandes stars des
échecs a aussi des joueurs qui sont plus
amateurs et c'est aussi intéressant dans
les tu vois tu vois bon là on a pas le
dans ce match on a on a ça rime qui
commence à être quand même très connu on
a visite on a bien sûr avant on avait
hier après une Amanda on est regazi etc
tout à l'heure on va avoir Nakamura on
va avoir aussi
avec jumanjouh champion du monde et avec
ça bon on a quand même des joueurs qui
sont quand même plutôt enfin qui sont
pas vraiment profil ils sont
professionnels mais qui sont pas des
stars des stars mondiales comme par
exemple dans sa Vita on a vu Chali donc
ils sont très très fortes mais
mais qui sont pas de 1700 euros quoi tu
vois on a pranes aussi on a gauche des
terrial
et même à 10 balles c'est un super
joueur mais qui a 2006 quoi tu vois
c'est pas c'est pas un joueur à 2750 ou
quoi et donc après pour les prix je
pense que c'est aussi
pour cette raison là enfin je sais pas
c'est pas mal franchement c'est pas mal
tu vois mais quand tu vois c'est pas des
millions non plus c'est vrai que par
rapport
qu'on a eu qu'on a pu voir sortir comme
avec des prix qui sont qui sont il y a
beaucoup plus à 150 000 de prix au total
et c'est vrai que par rapport
aux champions c'est moins conséquent
mais ça reste quand même énorme et puis
on l'avait commenté ensemble ce que tu
dis il a été finalement ce que tu dis
c'est encore
c'est prouvé par cette fabuleuse
performance de Joséphine ainman qui a
battu et car on a qu'à moi ce qui est
quand même c'est à dire qu'elle aurait
même pas l'occasion de le jouer en fait
dans n'importe quel autre tournoi et là
il a réussi à le battre donc tu es assez
impressionnant
donc deux grands pro tu as vos kids qui
est médaille d'or olympique quand même
et après tu en as acheté tu as une fille
qui a 2000 combien de 1300000 quoi
et donc en fait bon 2300 hello bah c'est
c'est pas c'est pas ouf quoi dans une
compétition où il y a Nakamura mais tu
vois tu peux en fait enfin moi j'aime
bien en fait le fait de mixer en fait tu
vois t'as pas que des joueurs c'est pas
une équipe intéressante
à tout le monde je trouve que c'est
vraiment intéressant
ok donc là il se passe pas grand chose
dans les noirs qui qui pressent sur la
sur la colonne B sur la structure
d'option de 4 les pièces
tranquillement cette partie
est-ce que tu retournes voir un petit
peu ce qui s'est passé dans les
donc il y a saluer nos amis d'abord si
elle bleu saw XO tous les meilleurs sont
là le char 45 Mario son château
incroyable
incroyable incroyable tous les meilleurs
de Capri en plus
il pleut
bon donc ouais là il va gagner
on va voir qui
on va voir est-ce que Savita j'ai envie
de voir
stream tu m'as tu t'es venté et tu m'as
dit que tu l'as battu à portitch
très facilement tu m'as dit en plus
la meilleure ouverture au monde moi je
pense qu'il faut que tu persistes dans
cette fille là
[Rires]
pardon
je crois que c'est une des si j'ai joué
la fille prend des quatre très
rapidement mais la vraie la vraie de
vraie comme tu m'as joué j'ai jamais
fait ça de ma vie
j'essaie de prendre le centre direct tu
sais je suis comme ça je comprends rien
et visite bah il lui fait une Master
Class en finale ouais donc elle était
ouais sur le problème quand on joue
comme ça pour faire nul mais quand ça
marche pas ça paraît moche là il y a
tout un chèque suivi de fou prends G2 et
elle peut abandonner tu vois j'ai voulu
la voir cette partie avant que ça soit
terminé mais là ça a plus aucun intérêt
et des sacs
elle avait joué la fille d'or des
changes pour pour faire nul quoi et au
final quand tu joues trop pour la nul et
ben tu finis par à partir du mauvais
coup et surtout en fait que cette
position elle est égale mais vite il est
content d'avoir une potion égale très
très tôt dans l'ouverture parce que
maintenant ma fille est plus fort il va
gagner quoi
et
ben petit à petit il a pris un pion et
puis il a gagné assez tranquille il a
pas trop trop j'ai pas vu la suite
c'était vraiment assez facile c'était la
démonstration
très facile de la part de
devises
on a aussi pranes qui a battu
erikazi on a on a raté ça on a raté
l'avion
en fait c'est une surprise et pas une
surprise de la position
allez on va voir
petite forme là dans cette projectile là
il a coûté cher hier et attention les
les la team MGD 1 qui hier a pris l'eau
complètement contre Gotham chess est-ce
que aujourd'hui
ils sont favoris d'après toi ah bah on
va voir la réponse tout de suite avant
le match t'aurais dit qu'ils étaient
favoris un peu
aujourd'hui là quand
[Musique]
t'essuyère non
moi je préfère je préfère l'équipe de
Yogi
mais on a les on a les scores de zéro
pour les yogis ouh là là c'est très très
chaud
a dit Bani la sacrifié oui mais ça va en
fait ouais non je me suis fait avoir par
le
il est toujours hyper bien documenté
j'ai 12 filles dans la base de données
Freyssinet dans la plupart avec les
noirs et on prend des quatre mais oui
c'est ce que je te dis
c'est exactement ce que j'ai dit et je
crois peut-être tu peux trouver un title
Tuesday où je fais des six cavalier F6
et E5 ça c'est pas
c'est pas complètement exclu mais en
partie long j'ai pas le souvenir
honnêtement
je crois que j'ai jamais fait ce truc là
c'est bizarre parce que j'ai fait quand
même j'ai quand même pas mal de parties
quoi mais
ça comme quoi
ok donc victoire de
Hannibal sans surprise
de farine qu'on n'a pas vu la suite
c'était aussi une belle
démonstration aussi la plus intéressante
c'était prenait chez pour voir ce qu'il
a joué dans cette position qu'on
regardait parce qu'elle était vraiment
ouais tu sais cette Française là je
trouvais ça j'étais curieux de voir le
coup qu'il allait qu'il allait choisir
justement là après après tout ça
qui joue pas
encore plus méchant que
quelle partie super partie de
prendre classe
[Musique]
ça va être un on va voir vite gauche
souvent à savoir les faire les appareils
tu vois moi je suis toujours
c'est à peu près c'est
comme on dit donc je vais essayer
d'aller regarder plutôt
je cherche
on voit plus
[Musique]
parfait donc je vais le décoller
je vais prendre la
et on va tout revoir à nouveau voilà
alors du coup je peux vous montrer un
petit peu enfin je vais préparer en fait
ça paraît de la ronde 2 ça va être ça va
être bien
et ça va faire
alors
ouh là là
il se prenait une énorme prépa et en
fait
il a réussi à tenir la nul très
impressionnant
et il y a eu nul très rapide entre Ding
et rapports
le champion du mondeding et son fidèle
secondant Richard rapporte c'est pas
Magnus qui aurait fait ça
moi je vous le dis et les pommiers
malheureusement les paumes
il a fait cette nuit de la berlinoise
avec Dame Descartes donc il reste à
livraison alors il y a l'ireza qui a
montré un manque de
d'un ouverture
qui connaissait pas une ligne qui a été
notamment joué par cramique et anando à
la première partie du match champion du
monde à Beaune mais en 2008 il est
réserve en même temps en 2008 mais il
avait 5 ans
donc parfois c'est ça tout ce qui est
oublié nouveau et donc il souffre contre
Douda il est moins bien clairement il
est mal au temps en plus enfin rien de
rien de très très grave encore mais une
belle position pour Douda et notre mvl
national qui joue une petite finale
contre des hacks à peu près équilibré
mais bon on va voir s'il va légère
avantage pour pour mvl pas grand chose
et ce sont les Français qui sont les
deux seuls à jouer après quelques très
simplement une heure et demie de jeu
ouais bravo à guéri incroyable parce
qu'il s'est pris une prépa il est rentré
en fait dans le truc
dans le truc hyper compliqué et il a
trouvé tous les coups il a fait c'est
pas mal
vu les temps il connaissait pas il
réfléchit une heure
mais c'est assez impressionnant de pas
avoir peur parce que tu peux tu peux
toujours te dire je vais essayer de pas
compliquer justement pour
si j'en ai après pas là il peut perdre
son jouet en fait c'est ça le problème
donc je pense qu'il a dû je sais pas
dur à dire vu le temps mais si c'est pas
s'il a tout trouvé sur l'échiquier c'est
pas tant parce que franchement c'est pas
c'est vraiment pas évident
OK et on va voir donc cette 32 vous a
trouvé les appareils
et moi en 2000 c'est pas 2005 en 2008
oui j'avais 35 ans c'est ça
exactement je te remercie bon après
c'est facile pour moi de dire que c'est
archi connu
vu que je travaille pour cramique et
donc on a eu cette première partie qui
s'est joué comme ça mais
quand même la solution est connue depuis
longtemps il y a eu pas mal de parties
un peu bizarre qu'ils connaissent pas ça
avant d'échange de la slave peut-être
qu'il avait des ambitions plus hautes là
à ce moment-là c'est bizarre de jouer
une slash parce que
quand la position n'est pas là c'est
compliqué
on va voir si la s'en sortir pour
l'instant il s'en sort bon la première
partie il a perdu contre saut mais bon
il s'en sort très bien s'il gagne il est
en tête
on va voir
tout cas si il perd pas il garde la
première place execo
le mental de guéri nous dit ciel bleu le
mental
avec le talent de dépôt et une chance
contre camsen
je trouve pas que il a un mental
ou pas impressionnant sur le plan mental
il est un peu trop chicken
je vais aller dire bonjour on va dire
bonjour est-ce que le bon show YouTube
est lancé je vous ai mis YouTube alors
rappelant
que ce qui reste sur chaise 24 ou sur
JETCOM
fr n'hésitez pas à mettre un petit pouce
bleu je le mets moi tiens et à vous
abonner à suivre la chaîne n'hésitez pas
allez-y
salut Jean-Marc froid
Sophie orange
romain
jade el Bakali
et merci je crois que c'est un truc du
style 70% de nos viewers YouTube et ben
ne sont pas abonnés à la chaîne Youtube
donc n'hésitez pas en tout cas à vous
abonner c'est gratuit et nous ça nous
soutient et puis en plus vous serez
averti dès qu'il y a des des événements
des streams ou des vidéos ou quoi que ce
soit sur les réseaux sociaux donc
n'hésitez pas en tout cas à vous abonner
sur Youtube et aussi pour ceux qui nous
regardent sur sur twitch et bien le
follow hein il est là pour être averti à
chaque fois qu'on est live
j'espère que tu vas bien
salut salut à toi
c'est pareil moi c'est pareil sur sur
chaise 24 j'avais les chiffres aussi
c'était
110 %. c'est pareil donc les gens qui
sont pas abonnés qui s'abonnent pas bon
c'est mieux c'est mieux pour pour tout
le monde en fait et c'est vrai que ça
coûte rien effectivement
il aime pas
toi il faut que tu payes toi donc tu
aimes pas les trucs gratuits donc
surtout ne t'abonne pas s'il te plaît
désabonne toi si tu es abonné on veut
pas de toi gratuitement
[Musique]
quoi fais un truc histoire
alors là ça a été fini est-ce que j'ai
l'impression que vous visitez et gauche
ont peut-être repris
chez moi ouais ça a repris chez moi
alors ça n'a pas été automatique
alors là on est quasiment dans une
Cadence C6 ça c'est la grosse faute à
grosse faute de gauche il a pas compris
qu'il y avait les va en D7 pour faire la
fille il dort
et si c'est vraiment encore fou cette
suite D6 pourquoi pas mais des 6 tout de
suite normalement il y a des 4 T4
qu'est-ce qu'il veut fouger 4
T4 fougères je suppose il a joué des
cadres il veut voir il paye pour voir ah
non il prend des 4 ça c'est calme
normalement vraiment pas ambitieux pour
les Noirs tu es sûr d'être un peu moins
bien
ouais faut sept et maintenant soit petit
rox soit je sais pas
ouais petit rock
quelque chose comme ça
bon il y a beaucoup de plans ou B3 mais
bien sûr hein
ça empêche les cahiers de 4 les couches
4 il y en a plein de trucs comme ça puis
après on met le fond en E3 tours
donc voilà un fouet trois fois H3 un
truc de ce style là peut-être un jour
quelque chose de très peu ambitieux pour
les Noirs clairement
c'est même pas comment on joue ici tout
va vite tour 8 fois 8 OK
les noirs
[Musique]
mais c'est la fille un petit peu timide
quoi
je suis à moitié
ouais
franchement là
il se casse pas la tête c'est pas mal
fou F4 aussi
a priori c'est pas une fille en tout cas
est-ce que c'est objectivement vraiment
moins bon que le cavalier en 17 j'en
sais rien mais ça peut étrange est-ce
que tu es sûr
je te mets la partie
toujours marrant les parties de
ça rigole pas
quelque chose de bien quand même
[Musique]
donc c'est une sorte de trompe ski
si on fait cavalier
F6 donc généralement touche pas au
courant ça on le dit tout le temps et
bon là c'est particulier qui existent et
on rajoute pour 5 on gagne du temps sur
le fou et on joue pour le 5 et
d'ailleurs elle le fait E5
ouais donc il fait encore une fois une
ouverture
très pauvre provocatrice mais bon pour
l'instant ça lui sourit pas trop la
lancer dans ce week-end là oui
ce weekend là c'est vrai
par exemple
et
ça perte qui fait dans
je sais pas
tout va bien
ça se regarde en tout cas
intéressant bon en tout cas une position
très peu connue après très peu de coups
normal elle va développer son foot casse
blanche le grand rock gagne un tempo
dans son développement ça a l'air pas
mal et pour les Noirs déjà
accélérer donc je pense que les noirs
sont pas mal il y a aussi tout le temps
quand même
quelle fan social bleu j'adore
c'est vrai
il y aura de dire mais bon
ok
[Musique]
si on change et qu'on va chez peut-être
adibam pranes
très important de cette partition d'Iban
ne va pas prendre
ça va être compliqué
[Musique]
c'est quoi le
c'est quoi le début
qui sait pas transformé en mode en vrai
notre boom avec ses particularité mais
bon
parce qu'il a l'air quand même très très
bien à divan la position qu'on a vu au
départ
déjà
je sais pas trop où on va regarder ça
quand même
défendre vis-à-vis des fous comme ça
et ce pion ici je mangeais plus tard
deux fois que tu aimes B6 comme tu
préconisé
cahier 5 à 6 faux C8
damage 5 peut arriver attention pure C6
d'abord et d'un match 5 peut être très
très méchant parce que ce pur en G7 on
prend quand on veut jusqu'au jour on le
prend plus donc faut faire très
attention
après par exemple un coup comme je sais
pas fou des 7 peut-être damage 5 déjà
c'est à considérer
ça fait peur quand même
tout ça
F4 ou F4 direct F4 F4 à la fois
c'est terminé ça
et après la préhistoire
c'est terminé
encore une fois tu vois le roi blanc il
est il est extrêmement bien défendu les
pièces sont bien placées chez les Noirs
j'ai tout le monde à la maison et
et généralement quand tout le monde à la
maison tu as déjà un ou deux pions plus
avec les Noirs
mais bon même pas fait même celui-là il
est pas fait il est pas encore encaissé
je suis aussi sur l'emprise aussi donc
même tactiquement il se passe des choses
je sais pas si clair tu vois il faut
repérer longtemps et je voulais être
pour défendre ton quoi
une bonne nouvelle pour le suspense si à
10 balles bah prend neige je trouve que
ça échiquier parce que on le voit hein
c'est le numéro 3 de l'équipe mais il
est quand même très très dangereux donc
si commence à faire des points aussi
avec Sarine et vidite en duo d'attaquant
ça a commencé à faire beaucoup là et
attention on va échalie elle est quand
même
elle est redoutable aussi clairement
elle fait pas zéro
[Musique]
franchement elle est pas ridicule du
tout
donc c'est la sœur de Prague pour ceux
qui ne le savent pas qui était là hier
et aujourd'hui qui se repose donc cette
seule coup on avait vu d'un match 5 de
ma fille ça allait pas à mon avis d'un
mecs est vraiment le seul coup et
maintenant
est-ce que je peux pas essayer de jouer
un peu la même chose que tu proposes
alors puis on prend CD tour reprend et
je vais essayer de tenir et surtout
prendre le sel j'ai essayé pas
j'ai même pas droit à
faire ça il y a eu des recettes c'est la
partie on va sûrement à droite
il faut prendre les 5
c'est pas le j'ai l'impression que c'est
vrai ou pas le seul coup
[Musique]
il fait [__] d'abord ok sur ed ça a
l'air désastreux parce qu'on ouvre on
ouvre la colonne eux où il y a le roi
derrière pour l'instant donc il faut
prendre du pion C a priori
qu'on peut se permettre de donner le fou
donc
on pense que le foot en gâteau
ça jamais donné à personne on doit
garder coûte que coûte jusqu'à la fin de
la partie parce que le fou défend le roi
et puis que c'était etc mais ici on voit
bien que le cavalier de 5 faisait un
trop gros job avec le plan C3 la classe
contrôler etc et en échangeant et ben au
final on a plus de foutage blanche mais
en plus le flou des noirs et ben il est
complètement enfermé et puis du coup il
serait jamais actif si en jouant faut
prendre un 4 tu avais un fou noir 4 je
pense pas que que les Blancs auraient
forcément aimé faire ça tu vois mais là
avec la qualité du Fou des 7 on peut se
permettre de donner le fou parce que au
final exactement qui reste et puis il y
a un truc en plus bon ben voilà quand si
c'est concret c'est concret c'est vrai
que s'il y a pas F4 derrière ça a pas
trop de sens de prendre
tu échanges moi souvent ce que j'aime
bien faire avec mes élèves c'est
mettre des couleurs sur la pièce tu vois
je mets bonne pièce bonne pièce et je
mets la bonne pièce dégueulasse et en
fait tu échanges une bonne contre une
bonne et il reste une bonne ou une
mauvaise tu vois et au final
effectivement est assez catastrophique
et mauvaise pièce voilà et en plus une
question avant les années 2000 est-ce
que tu as eu ton titre de j'aime avant
les années 2000 je suppose que c'est pas
pour toi Stéphane sinon c'est un gros
chambrage c'est un bon truc
c'est pas pour moi la question
[Musique]
donc j'ai eu mon titre de mi
25 ans avant toi donc 98 et 2000 ouais
2000 pile 2000 j'étais grand maître donc
voilà
pour ta réussite
[Musique]
qui sont très offensifs donc il peut se
passer un peu tout n'importe quoi dans
ces matchs là
ok est-ce qu'on switch un petit peu
qu'est-ce qu'on a pas vu
[Musique]
Sarine sahita première
yo guise
qui a un problème hier ils ont ils ont
ils ont mis un ricard mais elle a pas
tu es pas au top elle est au top
donc ils ont changé bon ça se comprend
peut-être que la stratégie
tu vois quand est-ce que s'il avait
gagné Arika quand même malgré tout c'est
bon
et salut à toi mec gym doudou
doudou le pro 13 qui dit point
d'interrogation
mais par contre si vous avez les
qualités les compétences et la
motivation et bien n'hésitez pas à
envoyer votre CV
avec une lettre de motivation c'est
encore mieux je sais pas qui recrute qui
prend un décision finale de recrutement
tu devrais plus au courant que moi
ah oui
faut que je fasse semblant d'être au
courant de tout
j'ai oublié mais oui j'imagine que les
l'équipe France a un petit peu un petit
peu son bras dire je sais qu'il discute
souvent entre eux après c'est pas eux
qui par exemple
bon je sais pas en tout cas c'est vrai
que si vous jouez d'échec et que vous
touchez bien
en montage vidéo etc bah franchement
c'est lié job à la quéchec c'est
toujours agréable quoi enfin si vous
aimez les échecs c'est toujours sympa
donc franchement n'hésitez pas à
postuler si vous connaissez quelqu'un
qui connaît quelqu'un
que ça peut intéresser
moi je pense qu'en montage vidéo que
j'avais j'avais fait des montages et
tout je pense que je suis
pas plus
moi j'ai même pas essayé en fait
[Musique]
ce que quelqu'un normal ferait en 30
secondes
alors est-ce que ça arrive il va passer
ou pas
pour avoir plus de contrôle sur la case
mais dans l'autre côté je sais pas après
un plan aéré là et quand toutes les
pièces sont dessus toutes les pièces
défendent et bien il faut s'écouter il
faut essayer de se retrouver souvent ce
qu'on appelle la deuxième faiblesse de
l'adversaire
et je sais pas si comment trouver la
deuxième faiblesse
je crois
il faut
un peu de mal à prendre la colonne r
parce que lui en prise ça peut être une
possibilité donc à préparer
tranquillement j'ai 4 ans toute façon ça
rime peut-être j'ai quatre en fait sans
échanger les fous
peut-être que je
de H5 H6 et après profiter de fou sont
quasiment il y a plein d'idées mais
c'est vrai que finalement faut prendre 5
peut-être que c'est pas lui quand on
veut puis on fait quand on veut
peut-être aussi lui laisser se poser les
questions
qui commencent à toucher à ma fiche
Wikipédia je veux crains le pire
tu vas te faire censurer normalement sur
son petit VIP sur la chaîne je crois ils
font confiance
simplement aux sources sûrs
alors
va gagner
non pas encore
[Musique]
un petit d'accord bon ça c'est terminé
ok il y a un fait qu'une bouchée de son
adversaire
ouais donc il a une qualité de plus
et ces maths en plus donc
c'est le coup qu'on joue qu'on joue
automatique
[Musique]
les possibilités et si tu prends là je
prends là et c'est terminé
en plus
[Musique]
donc trop facile pour à Dylan victoire
mais il y a quand même des fautes en
poser un peu de jeux pour les noirs
c'est important
s'il y a ici fait comme hier
et en petite forme comme hier ça va être
ça va être dur pour
pour la team MGD 1
on a Maxime qui est en train de répéter
les coups comme des hatchs peut-être
c'est juste une répétition pour pour
voir mais effectivement ça sent la
journée quand même très très tranquille
au à Bucarest
ça se ça se fatigue pas trop dans
l'escalier est vraiment mal maintenant
il a un purement
et
ça serait dommage c'est dommage qu'il
perde mais bon il va se battre ça c'est
certain
comme Éric et qui se bat
ah ouais non d'accord ok
on peut tenir ou pas
c'est une question mais bon ça va pas
être évident
ouais c'est ça maintenant il va doubler
sur la colonne
je j'ai trois F4 il peut pas doubler
parce qu'elles font ces trois de trois
C4 d'abord mais roi C4 où vas-tu
ouais alors après c'est pas une finale
facile c'est une finale mais c'est final
pour un troisième place
donc finalement ils sont pas si
dominateurs que ça mais ça prouve qu'il
met ils prennent cette project League
très très au sérieux
et ça prouve qu'ils ont un réservoir
assez incroyable de joueurs et de
joueuses et qui sont peut-être sous
classés c'est vrai que les joueurs comme
pranes on sent il a il a même à peine
2500 donc ils ont des jeunes joueurs qui
ont pas encore
eu le temps de jouer énormément de
tournois et qui sont clairement sous
classés
ça va être compliqué pour
un peu étonnant mais il reste un peu il
a deux minutes contre quelques secondes
et easy il joue tout rage 4 ou à prendre
est-ce que on est sûr de gagner cette
position
il a l'air
il a l'air convaincu
pas sûr que ça soit gagnant
j'aime très très dur
mais c'est vrai que tout est bloqué je
sais pas si on recherche
moi qui va passer
le roi qui aura des cases pour l'instant
je passe pas avec le fou ici c'est pour
être une bonne idée aussi mais
malheureusement faut pas décaler mon roi
F4 et roi C4 pour jouer fou des 3 que
c'est que c'est beau que celui-là il y
aura quand même
et en fait il marche pas pourquoi parce
que
moi je veux juste passer mon fou et je
trouve que le fou en Détroit il est bien
placé moi je voulais que ma tête
oui non il y a pas de c'est compliqué de
créer un réseau c'est sûr
j'étais presque hein
et ce matin
le fou qui maintenant est intouchable et
même des fois des cas où on peut même
faire échec et aller sacrifier c'est ça
moi je pense que ça sert le truc du mat
ça me semblait beaucoup trop optimiste
mais le truc de sacrifier un A5 oui ça
c'est un scénario que je vois bien
attention
oui c'est ça aussi il faut faire
mais je crois un peu moins pour cela
mais ok
ok
49 secondes contre 5 secondes pour
être dur ça va être dur évidemment mais
ça a l'air nul en vrai
tu non pas ça donc il va être obligé de
tourner en rond
exactement une gaffe
et on voit que Sarine a battu
sa vie
et nul chez vidite ok donc sur cette
partie il faudrait vraiment qu'il y ait
dit la gaine pour revenir à un point
simplement il y a 4 et demi de nuit donc
si Erika zigan ça fait 4,5
3 amis parcours c'est déjà c'est déjà
compliqué
donc partie très importante pour le
moral aussi pour le moral des troupes
parce que c'est vrai que s'ils n'ont pas
irrigué
alors il veut faire passer son rond en
B5 allez fais le tour
là je vais réussir peut-être à manger à
5 maintenant attention que là je
commence à menacer les petits trucs
je peux pas manger c'est sûr
comme effectivement la position est
nulle mais après il reste 6 secondes oui
évidemment qu'elle est nulle cette
position ouais mais il faut tourner un
peu
de chance et tu as toujours du garde
tout reprend là non ça marche pas
ça marche pas on peut le montrer
d'ailleurs ça serait une bonne idée mais
ça marche pas du tout c'est sympa si je
mange là pour manger ici mais moi je
veux cette finale là le problème
et
elle te laisse pas sacrifier ne te
laisse pas sacrifier
mais bon
il y a le presque mat
de tout à l'heure
la tour la tour
et la fatigue de jouer avec aussi peu de
temps à la pendule pendant longtemps et
ouais on a vu un qui a cligné il a
cligné des yeux
tourner et ben en fait c'est aussi
psychologique voilà ça me fatigue et tu
as peu de temps la pendule il faut
toujours te te battre à chaque couche
accouche à coup et ça permet de pouvoir
craquer enfin tu vois et en plus le
problème c'est que tu as que 2 secondes
d'incrément donc tu peux pas te c'est
pas les 10 secondes tu vois si tu as 10
secondes par coup bah tu peux te rebâtir
un petit un petit capital temps sympa là
2 secondes va t'as à peine le temps de
jouer en fait et de regarder la menace
et encore
c'est même pas pour tout le monde donc
amis parcours écoute quatre et demi
trois et demi belle victoire d'erghezy
bon les yogis qui sont quand même très
largement favoris clairement je crois
qu'on va faire un petit un petit premier
break Stéphane et on va on va revenir
pour la fin de ce match qui s'annonce
quand même plutôt serré avec un avantage
clair pour pour yoguiz là clairement ils
sont on est d'accord ils sont favoris
évidemment à 18h on a le on a le grand
match à grande finale avec les gothams
et notamment
Ikao Nakamura Fed OCIF ou encore face au
surprenant chinois veilli juvenju la
charpente du monde très belle équipe
aussi merci merci de nous suivre à tout
de suite à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour
pour la troisième place entre les deux
équipes indiennes les myan yogi et les
MGD 1
ça fait et bon ben ça s'annonce
sans serrer avec un léger avantage pour
les yogis pendant ce temps à Bucarest il
se passe pas grand chose donc restez
avec nous
parce qu'il y a rien à voir il reste la
partie derrière il y a eu 4000
malheureusement au Maxime Vacher la
grave a pas réussi à faire trembler le
joueur local alors le joueur local des
hack qui a quand même 2700
peu en souffrance contre Douda
on va voir il faut qu'il arrive à s'en
sortir pour garder espoir de tournois
pour le il est en tête s'il fait partie
nul il reste en tête execo avec Fabiano
caroana et donc tout se jouera demain
il aura demain il joue qui il joue
Maxime va chez Lagrave demain et donc
pas jouer premièrement il y a
un tournoi ou notamment aux candidats ou
les joueurs du même nationalité joue
ensemble première onde là
il y a pas de tirage au sort dirigé
les scores favorables et voilà raison
traumatisé par l'époque soviétique et
les plaintes de Fisher
bon maintenant ça existe plus trop
dans un monde mondialisé donc les gens
ont des amis un peu partout
[Musique]
Maxime attention il peut essayer
ça c'est clair donc
comme contre oissier mais bon il va
essayer quelque chose ça c'est sûr
un début très modeste de la part de
Hannibal mais plus tard ça va chauffer
comme d'hab
c'est un joueur qui aime bien le fight
et on a aussi non
ça vient de commencer à l'instant on ira
voir après ce qui se passe il y a pas
les bons appareils morts du coup
à droite enfin en bas de nous
oui
[Musique]
c'est bon
comme ça on peut suivre ça arrive
[Musique]
entre les deux féminines donc voyez chez
Elie contre Savita et pranesh contre
gauche assez bizarre je pensais pas que
c'était dans cet ordre là je pensais que
c'était pour la dernière
[Musique]
et lui il avait 24 42 je crois
ah ouais lui c'est un bon c'est une
bonne dans le crue à 24 40 et maintenant
elle a 24 ans et lui il a 24
beaucoup quasiment 2005
et bizarre pour visite c'est censé être
moins bien ça pour les noirs
des cinq isolé mais bon il va jouer 7 et
F5 alors il fait foutu 5 il me fait
mentir
il a l'air de savoir ce qu'il fait en
tout cas
plus vite
et oui il a joué il a joué Petro en
premier coup probablement il a fait un
cours de châsservable
je vais m'attirer les foudres du chat
hors de chez seven il a fait un court
très populaire avec un B3
et donc voilà il utilise un petit peu en
processe League of
le
c'est possible que ça soit une
transposition et que ça retombe dans son
cours vu la vitesse à laquelle il joue
ce serait vraiment
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on peut manger en Descartes
pour essayer de rendre le pion
enfin que l'option soit maintenant
plus isolé mais il est plus vraiment on
va dire
sous pression pour la colonne des quoi
[Musique]
la meuf 3 maintenant peut-être d'un F3
tour des 8 tours
c'est compliqué cette position
et plus que difficile
avec les trois contre
on va voir ce qui va choisir
mais on a zappé
pas
donc c'est standard il y a eu un faux
échec il faut prendre des sept
et
donc
partir moi je voulais bien voir
à chaque fois des positions un petit peu
bizarres ouais des doubles fiancés 5
c'est vraiment
c'est hyper travaillé peut-être qu'il se
prépare longtemps je crois pas
hyper bien placé mais il empêche ces
deux C4 et donc il y a pas trop de
rupture pour les blancs c'est ça le
concept
c'est très très bizarre quand même
ça a l'air d'aller complètement pour les
Noirs ouh là
ça fait
scandinave en E5 je fais H4 H5 et qu'on
veut provoquer un coup qui ont h
pour avoir une carte de fuite pour le
fou et sur un fromage 6 j'aurais lu
Caval à l'étranger 6 et la structure des
Noirs seraient affaiblies
mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut jouer là
je crois qu'on va être obligé de faire
H6 mais est-ce que c'est si grave c'est
ça le truc
G4
il y a quand même du dynamisme ici pour
les Noirs c'est pas complètement évident
que c'est très mauvais pour les noirs
souvent dans ces positions le roi
j'ai des trucs comme ça là dans la
position ici présente c'est pas vraiment
si clair même si tu manges G6 je peux
très bien avoir du jeu quelque part et
te laisser le pion quoi donc c'est
intéressant on va encore une fois à part
ça comment tu sauves la pièce en fait
c'est ça la je vois pas comment tu peux
alors souvent dans la scandale dans
cette position là tu as dû lui H5 F6
alors je dis ça je sais pas si m'aider
avec un cavalier 17
H5 c'est pour ça alors vraiment
dégueulasse par contre
parce que là
j'ai 5 le problème c'est qu'il y a j'ai
5 et il y a pas de casse pour le
cavalier
ça peut être
quelque chose comme ça
ok intéressant je pense qu'il va jouer à
6 ça va venir réfléchir en tout cas
à vie avec une pièce
et en plus qui peut arriver donc ça fait
peur en tout cas de faire voir
j'attaque le cavalier le pion aussi donc
le seul coup et là il faut prendre H6
et c'est pas c'est pas idéal
[Musique]
après il prend beaucoup de temps parfois
Sarine parce qu'il est très fort avec
très peu de temps il est assez
incroyable
il n'a pas peur de se mettre mal au
temps
de rien
moi mais tu as ça en l'air tu as le roi
qui à poil tu as les pièces sorties
alors que moi j'ai pas tout sorti et du
Tour 8 il y a du dames mais il y a pas
mal de problèmes quand même pratique
chez les Blancs clairement gros retard
de développement roi faible ça peut mal
tourner en tout cas bien ce qu'il fait
quel est le tempo
et pas mal et ça a l'air pas mal parce
que ce pion qui va toujours être en
prison
aussi
présage Cadum projet 6
mais
les finales avec la paire de fou elles
sont mieux pour elles sont mieux pour
les blancs
ouais non tu peux jouer sur les doigts
probablement il faut faire quelque chose
comme ça mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
c'est pas quelque chose d'extraordinaire
qui fait rêver en tout cas
c'est compliqué en fait j'ai
l'impression que les Noirs ont prennent
plus de problèmes pratique que les
blancs en tête
dans cette position
on est d'accord
vous avez la partie en direct
donc c'est quoi c'était une carotane
d'avance position pour les faire très
vite
pour arriver au direct
pion et là mais généralement le pion à 5
qui va sauter voilà
mais une faiblesse en C6
qui compense si on arrive à protéger
cette faiblesse à garder la paire de fou
ça va
ça va être bien pour les Noirs mais ça
paraît pas quoique il faut regarder
fougestings
peut-être fou
F4 parce que 4 qui est très embêtant
je crois
que je veux quand même
penser 6 et détroit
qui fait très mal
et des trois au premier abord elle est à
l'air forme et
on va les prendre
ça veut dire rendre le fou
à noter que vous pensez 5 pair une pièce
bizarrement
un choix
c'est le roi mais récupérer ici et
si ce que ça vaut le coup de faire ça
actuellement il est un peu faible mais
les pièces noires sont
pas très bien placés peut-être tour des
6 aussi pour attaquer le pion C6 studio
de faire tourner je fais tour Fd1 et en
fait j'ai des très belles pièces
c'est passif quand même pour les pour le
noir donc
on garde nos pièces même cavalier G4 va
être un coup en fait plus tard même F4
les idées plus tard mais c'est vrai que
la finale normalement ça aurait quand
même favorable au blanc sachant que j'ai
une aile avec trois contre deux ici et
de l'autre côté il y a trois contre
quatre mais les pions doublés
normalement faut pas grand chose
il joue très vite protège
[Musique]
autant j'ai l'impression
il aime bien salut
faire tourner 6 pour attirer le four en
recette et maintenant
priori je vois pas
c'est pas logique
oui
mais bon
B4 pour empêcher
forcément ce que j'ai trois du coup
c'est un coup qui calme ou un petit peu
le roi et maintenant il te dit bah tiens
ce que faire quatre ou pas et si tu fais
F4 bah tu as plein de trous sur sur
casse blanche avec ton roi et donc toi
tu mets maintenant je peux faire si
c'est changer les fous mettre un
cavalière 4 tu vois et c'est tout ouvert
chez les chez les Blancs ça c'est la
provocation séparation
mais bon après voilà les noirs qui sont
actifs mais sur le long terme je préfère
les blancs parce que je trouve que j'ai
trois contre deux si jamais j'arrive à
ramener des pièces sur des bonnes cases
genre
je pense que les blancs sont peuvent pas
être moins bien en fait d'accord mais
bon voilà il faut il faut que j'arrive à
ça parce que là les Noirs ils ont quand
même ils ont quand même du FK ils ont
quand même des choses
qui peuvent se passer
pour te déstabiliser un petit peu
et
c'est logique en plus c'est logique
parce que du coup
mon argument de dire trois comptes de
fumiers après l'échange sera plus
valable parce que je crois qu'on doit se
développer
oui les finales sont pas claires
effectivement
donc
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on peut jouer ici position
je trouve que les Blancs tu vois les
pièces blanches pas très harmonieuse pas
grand chose
et mal placé mon qui avait la patte case
un peu de problème de communication
entre les pièces
la marque que les Noirs c'est quand même
tellement plus simple tout ce qui se
passe tellement plus cohérent
avec du F3 qui peut aussi être
éventuellement que c'est un peu long
hein
qu'est-ce que ça donne peut-être
un petit tour
très intéressante et les joueurs sont au
niveau à peu près équivalent
et donc c'est vrai que ça donne des
parties très tendues
du coup
je vais vous mettre les cannes
après Sarine c'est un très très bon
joueur de Bullet normalement normalement
il y a pas vraiment
enfin il est pas grave si longtemps il
arrive toujours à gérer mais quand même
ça fait quand même peu de temps alors
je vois qu'il est fermé
donc c'est moi je vérifie
ah non une [__]
normalement voilà j'ai enlevé la gamme
de farine
normalement mon micro il est il est
devant moi il est bien branché il est
sur rouge
donc j'en ai deux normalement je sais
pas si propriété un truc
je non mais
je sais pas
trop à trois améliorer
alors pour deux échec qu'est-ce qui se
passe c'est la pagaille absolue sur
ouais fin qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire
ranger trois tours 3
ça répète
ça fait nul oh c'est beau quand même
Sarine avec ses 10 secondes il est pas
du tout inquiet à chaque fois très très
impressionnant
nous avec 10 secondes franchement on
suit quoi lui en fait et tout va bien
attaquant la tour attaquant le cavalier
je suis passé la solution cavalier F3
échec mais attends c'est compliqué quand
même quand il réfléchit KF3 tu reprends
G6
et là je suppose tour F6
[Musique]
c'est pas mal
peut-être même si je G4 ici
alors
on va prendre
de 40 ans
très joli dame prend V5 et on voit la
force du pion passé d'en prendre à me
prendre et 7 on a un échec sur la grande
diagonale mais pas plus le roi vient en
G1 et on fait dames au prochain coup
donc petite tactique très très
importante et c'est une partie vraiment
très importante parce qu'il y a 5 et
demi 4 et demi pour Indian yogi il
passerait à 6 et demi s'il gagne
ça ferait ça ferait beaucoup
pour divertir la dame
comme ça mais bon peut-être le temps de
faire H3 et d'un G4 et essayer de faire
des menaces à tout remplise tant que le
pion avance je peux mettre le roi en
réseau c'est pas si facile
échec
peut-être pas je sais pas de me défendre
mais toi et je suis un peu sur H3 ouais
bon
il y a eu quoi
comme on l'avait dit on l'avait banalisé
bon pas terrible pas très impressionnant
la part de gauche et ça fait un score de
6 et demi quatre et demi attention il va
chez les gagne cette partie la dernière
qui reste elle a quoi avishalie
est parti très compliqué 2 secondes on a
pendule entre 7
c'est hyper compliqué
est-ce que tu peux gagner avec les
Blancs
tranquille
et donc là on va retourner 3 sur pas
manger là-bas
elle a donné elle a donné le pion le
pion E5 avec ce coup B3 là qu'il a mis
un peu dedans
ça c'est dommage que dans cette position
oups
[Musique]
je disais que dans cette position
B3 était pas forcément nécessaire
peut-être que je peux jouer sans même
après elle pouvait faire ça c'est
facilement
absolument jouer tourin un peu plus tard
[Musique]
mais ça changera rien
mais c'est des pions qui sont tous
doublés priori ça va hein F6
bon il y a encore des petits soucis
pratiques clairement mais bon
voilà je sais pas si gagnant mais
effectivement ça pose quand même des
problèmes pratiques au minimum
ouais pas simple pas simple
je sais pas
[Musique]
mais bon c'est une partie encore mais il
y a plus de chance de tenir dans ce
cas-là a fait la lettre est passive en
fait elle était pas si avec sa tour et
les Blancs avaient juste à pousser des
pions et à mettre le roi dans le dans le
réseau et
et petit à petit ben ça a gagné chez les
Blancs ok bah écoute 7 et demi 4h30 pour
le yogis qui sont du coup à un point
d'être troisième de la Process League
2023 donc il y a encore un 7 qui va
arriver d'ici quelques instants
ouais ouais ouais je j'ai du mal aussi à
l'imaginer
alors je vais mettre les
Savita qui a 0 sur 4 qui est en grosse
souffrance donc prenez sa Vita même si
ça Vita aura les blancs
ça paraît ça paraît déjà plié quasiment
donc ville blanc contre
ce serait une bonne stratégie d'équipe
pour visite
je pense que les joueurs
alors là c'était demie 4h30 vite il est
assez pragmatique
mais bon après il regaldi va faire
quelque chose d'agressif ça c'est
quasiment certain
il est en mandoline avec le blanc noir
et là surtout en plus et ben son équipe
elle est pas bien donc là c'est clair
que ça va ça va envoyer c'est vrai
qu'ils ont les joueurs pour monter
finalement entre adibad et
peut-être un peu plus calme donc
pourquoi pas faudrait un exploit de sa
vital clairement entrepreneur ça c'est
un véritable exploit tellement ce jeune
joueur semble dangereux
Sarine il va jouer contre
les caméras pour la ronde qui va arriver
après on va avoir quoi
[Musique]
et on rappelle à partir de 18h rester
parce qu'à 18h on a le grand le King
quasi le King de l'Internet
ikaruna kamura qui rentre en piste avec
les Gotham chaise grandissime favoris de
cette finale face aux surprenant chinois
donc on sait jamais les chinois très
compacts avec
le prodige veillez
Champion du monde en titre
depuis le début de cette projet signe et
Louis ping un peu peut-être un peu le
maillon faible de cette équipe mais bon
pas manchot quand même
donc très beau match à suivre ensuite à
18h la finale tant attendu et ouais
parce qu'on a quand même on a passé du
temps sur cette prochaine Ligue ouais ça
fait ça fait quelques mois quand même
qu'on est là
et
donc c'est la dernière journée
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs on en parlera
après peut-être mais le départage pour
la première place en cas d'égalité mais
ils sont assez marrants
et j'aime bien la formule
alors je l'ai suivi je peux te le
montrer enfin je peux même vous le
montrer je peux l'afficher à l'écran
c'est pas c'est pas traduit
malheureusement on l'a pas eu traduit
mais je vais quand même vous le montrer
regardez bien comment c'est joli donc on
joue en 3 + 2 et en fait on va commencer
avec la 4e table donc ce serait par
exemple
looping et ensuite en cas de nul je suis
rejoue
non en cas de nul le les c'est la table
3 qui rejoue contre la table 3 d'accord
si jamais il y a un facteur
par exemple imaginons dans les ici par
exemple si ça avait été je sais pas par
exemple pranesh contre Savita et
imaginons ça joue pranesh gagne il va
pranesh qui est numéro 4 dans son équipe
bah je crois numéro 3 en fait il faut
que que tous les joueurs soient vaincus
d'une équipe bon ben c'est un truc pour
Nakamura en fait ah ouais d'accord il va
arriver
un truc
mais voilà c'est c'est marrant donc en
fait là une équipe peut gagner sans même
que Nakamura avait besoin de rien faire
aussi
bon en tout cas c'est marrant je pense
qu'on est partage
à mon avis
je trouve que c'est
ça change un petit peu et c'est vrai que
je pense que changer de manière générale
bah c'est cool c'est jamais vraiment les
mêmes choses ah j'ai plus les caméras
pourquoi est-ce que je faisais enlever
c'est pour ça donc c'est évident contre
les gars aussi je voulais mettre un ça
va arriver dans dans quelques instants
les gens sont pas encore installés donc
c'était demi 4h30 pour les yogis plus
qu'un point pour
pour être sur le podium
donc les équipes sont monstrueuses tu
vas même que les MGD 1 on a on a
irrigazi hadyban Savita et
c'est 4 indiens hyper hyper connu
surtout tu vois irrigazie qui qui avait
Brié surtout en 2022 il avait fait une
saison juste monstrueuse et bien là pour
l'instant on se tourne là bah il est pas
très en forme
pas très en forme mais c'est vrai que là
il a pas beaucoup de points dans ce
aujourd'hui et hier non plus et c'est
vrai que dès que tu as un jour dans
l'équipe qui est pas en forme et ben
c'est difficile parce que tout le monde
roule dessus et il faut 8 et demi
seulement pour qualifier et ça peut
aller très vite quoi un jour qui fait 0
bah c'est 4 points d'adversaire quoi
donc c'est dur quoi c'est dur
donc les joueurs qui vont commencer
j'imagine d'ici quelques minutes
est-ce que tu peux nous faire un petit
un petit résumé de ce qui se passe
dans le Super bête peut-être alors un
petit résumé ouais il y a eu une journée
très très calme aujourd'hui avec des
nuls assez rapide notamment les deux
joueurs les deux combattants du
championnat du match championnat du
monde qui sont qui peuvent plus tout
simplement donc avec Yann et pomyachi
qui a
qui a forcé la nulle face à Wesley
sceaux dans cette berlinoise Dame des
quatre qu'on connaît tous Richard
apporte qui jouait contreding myrène bon
c'était son secondaire il est ils ont
fait nul
Maxime ma chère grave qui a pas réussi à
mettre la pression sur le joueur local
des hatchs une Hulpe intéressante mais
théorique entre karwana et guéri
apparemment guéri qui avait fait bien
ses devoirs ou qui a tout trouvé sur
échec et on a cette dernière partie
entre Ali resa firoga qui est en tête en
fait qui était en tête ce matin en ce
moment même il a un demi point de moins
que Carona met une partie en moins donc
clairement à 5 sur 8 à 4 et demi sur 7
mais une position inférieure face à Doha
qui alerte mais bon pas facile
et Maxime va chez Lagrave à 50 % des
points 4 sur 8 ce qui est raisonnable
dans ce genre de tournoi c'est très très
fort tandis qu'on voit les deux joueurs
les deux joueurs qui viennent du bas
championnat du monde
à trois sur 8 et oui avec
deux défaites pour 0 victoire pour le
nouveau champion du monde d’ingerel et
Yann des pomyachi qui a une victoire
mais trois défaites et donc trois sur 8
qui donnent un boulevard au niveau rend
mondial pour aller à qui repassent
numéro 2 mondial assez largement de
1792,6 de 1779 pour néo 2775 pour Ding
et Naka qui sans jouer pourrait dépasser
Ding demain et Kawana qui revient un
hello enfin une place mondiale en tout
cas plus plus descente conforme
à son talent et il est sixième jour
mondial tandis que Maxime va chère gagne
quelques points et il a 2745 il revient
13e jour mondial c'est aussi plus
conforme à son niveau
donc voilà on aura le dénouement demain
de cette première étape du
grand chastours
finalement on en voit plus trop des
trois parties
[Musique]
on est obligé de suivre et puis en
savoir on va se préparer pour l'année
prochaine n'est-ce pas on va avoir une
grosse partie je crois l'année prochaine
au départ oui parce qu'on risque pas de
finir dans la même
[Rires]
après ça dépend de votre niveau de
renforcement je dirais au niveau des
étrangers parce que c'est pas encore
décidé
je sais pas mais je sais pas mais ça
dépend
ouais ça dépend combien quel niveau
c'est toujours pas rien on a toujours
besoin de
meilleure équipe au Top 16 en tout cas
cette finissent en pullotte en général
on quand même deux trois étrangers assez
costaud pour les mettre au premier
échecs
ok donc cette partie donc c'est un
dragon qui a été joué par irigasi contre
visite un dragon
avec un petit homme 8
ouais pour finir sur ce grand geste tour
là les raisins c'était pas mal quand
même il a perdu la première en force en
trou en tout cas moi j'ai l'impression
qu'on se dirige vers
vers quelque chose qui va ressembler à
Magnus c'est à dire qu'il y aura les
tournois avec Ali resa les tournois sans
Ali resa parce qu'il fait quand même
l'animation un peu comme Magnus Carlson
qui est dans
donc il y aura peut-être des tournois
avec Ali Alsace voilà ça ça fait une
grosse différence au niveau du parce que
tous les jours il joue la gagne tous les
jours tu aimes bien les joueurs qui qui
jouent pour gagner et qui font spectacle
là tu as vu dans le tournoi bon c'est
pas pour dire mais on a vu quand même
surtout deux parties qui sont terminées
en 20 minutes quoi
mais ça je trouve que c'est fou quoi
je trouve que c'est un peu fou quand
c'est
quand c'est un tournoi de cette
envergure que tu es
que les gros prix comme ça c'est un
minute bon moi je sais pas mais je
trouve que au niveau de l'organisation
c'est pas très respectueux quoi bah il
devrait c'est un peu leur faute aussi
ouais il devrait imposer en l'occurrence
Ding et rapporte bon c'est particulier
les pots il fait jamais ça mais là il
est en tilt bon c'est aussi c'est aussi
un peu pas de chance mais
je comprends mais
qui connaissent
assez loin tu vois irrigazie qui a 9 34
mais alors intense
j'ai un dragon très bizarre alors on m'a
pas normalement quand on est quand on
peut pas échanger ce fou de fianchetton
on m'a pas mais là c'est pas sûr parce
que H5 a l'air quand même très dangereux
ce qu'on commence par F4 pour enterrer
ce fou car il est ok ah ok ok
[Musique]
c'est pour ça en fait le fait d'avoir je
sais 5 et fin d'avoir le pion qui est
revenu en C5 et puis on a 5 il y a un
trou sur le 5 donc le contre le jeu il
est très très dur à exploiter avec les
Noirs je sais pas trop comment ils vont
attaquer
à la colonne ouvert c'est la colonne
c'est ta soeur prend cette roi et là
après F4 ben écoute H5 alors même
hyper hyper fort qui va enterrer le fou
en H8 et en fait les Noirs vont avec un
fulgoin
et on peut bien sûr faire à H5 et à se
ranger 6 pour essayer d'ouvrir la
clonage mais normalement dans cette
position de Jean ghetto quand les blancs
n'ont pas le fou pour s'échanger contre
le full G7
un exemple mais là c'est un cas spécial
avec cette tour en fuite qui est quand
même alors si j'ai le temps je prends un
exemple
j'ai le temps de faire un truc de ce
style là c'est vrai et ben normalement
ici je dis normalement
il y a pas de maths
tiens tout en fait et tu as pas le fou
pour venir en H6
en fait le fou contre toutes les cases
et t'as jamais de maths voilà donc
l'idée de faire un h4h5 H3 G6 c'est pas
trop trop d'actualité comme tu l'as dit
et effectivement
je préfère jouer à 6 pour enterrer le
fou parce que comme j'ai pas le cas noir
peut-être je vais plus positionné la
mère plus intéressante en tout cas je
sens que je t'aime pas je pense là c'est
ça hyper hyper naturel de jouer H5
est-ce que tu peux pas sur H5 bouger la
tour pour faire faux et fuite en cash-6
qui va faire probablement parce que au
final tu t'en fous il est mauvais
peut-être que ça vaut le coup de
tant qu'à faire tu le mets là il prend
peut-être sortir par la recette
est-ce que au lieu de faire H5 évalué 4
et un coup maintenant que de A4 est plus
en plus parce que dame huit avait
l'avantage de A4
maintenant
la prise serait intéressant mais de
manière générale foot que l'on opposé
favorise aussi l'attaque et c'est vrai
que ce fonds
donc moi je peux je peux l'activer mon
foufou C4
et c'est vrai que si tu compares de fou
c'est le jour de la nuit
donc
faut prendre un 4 c'est pas c'est pas
génial et puis bah je garde des options
de venir en décembre
et ouais
[Musique]
il réfléchit vite
et c'est vrai que tu avais raison il a
joué son jeu et juste un truc bizarre
enfin une question bizarre est-ce que H5
tour D8
H6 faut F8 et maintenant cavalle 4
redescence
maintenant je vais
te forcer
tu fais comment
il est fort à condition que bon
donc voilà c'est c'est avantage
inconvénient quoi je peux pas faire
exactement tout ce que je veux quoi
[Musique]
donc avec les jouets par par Vidy qui
veut venir en B5
la dame si je peux hein
[Musique]
et tout ça
donner le pion pour pour
C5 alors déjà il faut regarder ici
peut-être tours
à 5 c'est 4 ne marche pas parce que
je joue je te laisse pas faire
non non
on donne rien
je vais fous ces quatre gentiment
on va te demander de non mais souvent tu
as une grosse poubelle en fait
il y a eu le tour CDI
les pièces et la contrôle et des 6 fois
6 et là il y a pas G3 à cause de froid
et Tour Eiffel il y aura d'un point H4
peut-être sur moi-même
donc sûrement un coup de défense via
dame 3 ou d'un F2
pour donner G2
alors F6 c'est un coup à double
tranchant parce que 6
et d'un autre côté vis-à-vis aussi et
les problèmes sur E5 donc forme hyper
gaffe M6 mais intéressant ce qu'il a
trouvé comme ressources réagir parce que
ça pose un petit problème
qui contrôle tout qui est bien en plus
[Musique]
ok j'aime beaucoup d'objets
F5 et en fait je te joue sur les deux
clouages c'est marrant c'est très très
emprise cavalier mais en fait il est pas
du tout en prison
de clouage
attaque double sur la cavalier le fou et
on gagne
on gagne presque une pièce
je dis presque parce que tu gagnes
vraiment la pièce
en fait sur Caval F5 j'ai vu en disant
il y a c'est pour montrer le cours
rigolo
aussi c'est en prise donc c'est pas un
coup
un coup viable
OK
très simple
et c'est très moche mais en fait il faut
jouer un coup quoi
mais
j'aime pas j'aime pas du tout les noirs
tu prends je mange cavalier jusqu'à la
pièce
d'accord
mesdames étaient aussi complètement
écrasant
[Musique]
alors je comprends ton idée
positionnelle clairement mais là
[Musique]
c'est la partie non
qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire en fait
je pense qu'il veut jouer un F6 un
moment donné je sais pas en quel mois et
parce que le roi F8 l'idée c'est qu'il
s'est enlevé quand même du vis-à-vis
donc je pense qu'il a envie de bouger le
Pione je sais pas trop ils veulent
mettre cinq ou un F6 mais parce que sur
F6 tu laisses quand même d'un pronostic
comme possibilité alors sur F5 j'ai pas
d'en prendre aussi si je prends ici là
si je mange là tu manges là je te manges
5 peut-être aussi F4 on a on menace
donc ça s'appelle
en tout cas tu souffres au minimum
et si je prends pas bah je recule
sûrement en G3 pour venir défendre F4 je
crois que tu as raison il va le faire
parce que quoi d'autre
OK
F6
prends un truc on a pas vu
comme ça
tu gardes ça en prise tu gardes ça en
prise
beaucoup de pions en prise
j'ai un peu en plus mais j'ai plein de
faiblesses
ok pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
on va voir si ce match est terminé je
sens que ça peut venir de prendre un
premier point alors pranes qui qui
allait les Noirs ici
je peux vous montrer
les caméras
les caméras hop Savita qui je vais vous
mettre un hop ça veut dire qu'il y a des
blancs
et il y a une pièce de plus mais il y a
quand même beaucoup de pions il y a
quatre pions pour les Noirs mais c'est
vrai que quand même des grosses
faiblesses un endroit et tout seul
et s'il faut jouer F5 pour défendre ça a
pas aller Tourer peut-être
toi comment je continue
toi avec les Noirs tu vois ouais c'est
ça le truc quoi
puis on jouait c'est affaiblissant mais
bon ça peut aller vite aussi faut voir
et c'est ça c'est chaud les avantages et
les inconvénients
pour la fuite j'ai pas moi je recommence
à regarder les choses comme tour C7
attaque c'est 6 une association
ben en fait j'ai mon fou qui va ce qui
va sauver aussi donc
c'est pas clair de savoir ce que les
Noirs veulent faire il y a eu F5 quoi
par exemple ça m'a l'air quand même
d'être très beau tout match et c'est un
peu tout match
les tours sur la colonne peut-être
l'exploit là peut-être de l'espoir
il faut voir ce qui se passe à côté
parce que
sur ça on va comme tu veux faire un
petit tour voir ce qui se passe
rapidement c'est Sarine Sarine elle est
blanc ici
Sarine n'est pas fini en fait il faut un
qui gagne
c'est vrai que là c'est un peu la
domination sur total
[Musique]
fuite il y a X6
Sarine qui qui en plus qui est bien
entendu je vois pas que je dois pas
gagner
tu veux voir laquelle
parce que là je vois qu'il y a plein de
choses bon allez vas-y
et
à partir
ce genre de position parce que je pense
qu'il est plus à l'aise que visite dans
le genre de complication
et puis il est mieux autant alors
attends il se passe c'est quoi alors
rapidement et
UF ça
me G3 et G5 elle a réussi un peu à
stabiliser même si
tu peux même pas manger en G5 parce que
c'est la partie F3
c'est compliqué là
c'est une belle solution là qu'il a
trouvé
H6 et ça a pas l'air si grave
bizarrement un roi qui est un roi volant
le roi volant en H6
sur cette tienne mais
[Musique]
c'est marrant moi
pour irigasi
qu'est-ce qu'on joue ici
est-ce qu'on est le petit coup sûr comme
fou D5 j'aime bien les petits coups sur
le petit coup sûr si tu veux vraiment
mater tu as H6 qui est marrant
qui menace maths du couloir c'est la
partie
[Musique]
mais par rapport à ce que tu voulais
hein
c'est pour ça que j'étais revenu vider
cette ligne avec le roi H6 et en fait
maintenant que si je vois si tout prend
H6 et ben tu as plus accès à la case H6
à cause de t'en fous exactement c'est
malin dans ce dans ce mon moi j'avais vu
maintenant je suis pas été aussi
d'accord pour t'enlever la case
vaut mieux pas être trop malin non plus
quoi
ça peut jouer des tours J2
[Musique]
qui va monter le premier point
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai je mens
c'est des tayen qui a gagné il a battu
VS et la ville qui vient de gagner aussi
je vais vous mettre le score
à jour ouais peu importe le match est
terminé c'est terminé
pour pour les Indian yogis avec 8 et
demi un 6 et demi pour l'instant il y a
encore
deux parties
contre sa vitesse ça ferait plaisir pour
sa vitesse si elle pouvait
et tous les pions sont avancés mais
maintenant on l'a dit les cases blanches
s'ouvrent et ça ça a l'air ça a l'air
pas bon alors là on a pas de caméra il
faut que je mette les caméras sur sur
pranes et sur sa Vita comment on fait ce
qu'on fait un petit coup de H3 un truc
comme ça mais bon c'est un peu lent
donc vous aussi donc là faut regarder
les cases noires ici c'est chaud encore
un coup elle va encore perdre
malheureusement et ça me set j'ai il y a
ça sur échec
mais bon
après c'est pas facile c'est pas simple
hein pour prendre un point je veux
attention à pas faire de la main il y a
un petit piège si on fait dames et Dame
des 4 et c'est mate au prochain coup
donc bon ça évidemment pranesh il va le
voir il peut même jouer de la fesse le
coup sûr de F6
le fou
va être perdu à un moment donné il fait
dames
n'importe quoi même des deux
pour échanger les dames
elle va abandonner évidemment
c'est fini
aucune chance
échec là OK et on prend la tour
dommage elle avait fait une grosse
grosse partie Sagitta et franchement
elle aurait elle aurait presque mérité
de gagner la partie aucun encore puisque
Sarine a aussi gagné donc
une victoire fleuve de c'est une gagne
yogi qu'on voyait favoris qui ont
contrôlé le match alors il y a eu un
moment où 4 et demi trois et demi
c'était pas si clair mais on se sentait
on les sentait au-dessus
donc c'est un petit quart d'heure on va
avoir le match donc la grande finale de
la protéger 2023 entre l'équipe de
Nakamura les Gotham Knights contre
l'équipe des Chinois les Tiger
Tiger comment ils sont un peu excuse-moi
depuis le début de la compétition on
s'appelle il payait pas de Minecraft
depuis le début quand même attends ils
ont vieilli je veux le jeu du monde mais
pas trop donc moi ça me fait peur les
gens que je vais pas trop de jours à
2005 qu'on connaissait pas dont un qui
est maître international mais bon ça
qu'ils ont une féminine qui est quand
même extrêmement forte et que devant ils
ont envoyé qui à 2007 depuis quand même
de nombreuses années mais par rapport à
3 ans et demi
qu'ils ont joué ils ont toujours écrasé
tout le monde franchement c'est à chaque
fois j'ai l'impression qu'il y a il y a
pas eu de grosses équipes en fait
finalement la finale elle est
archiologique pas si tu regardes les les
vraiment les parcours ou Gotham comme tu
le disais bah il joue jamais le dernier
set en fait tu vois c'était quand même
c'est quand même fou et hier aussi en
demi-finale ils ont écrasé vraiment
leur adversaire de MGD 1
et donc voilà c'est les deux équipes qui
ont été le plus impressionnantes depuis
le départ qui dès la première semaine on
s'est dit ah ouais quand même il y a des
clients là et en fait bah ça a été
confirmé on les retrouve en finale et
donc ça va être sympa donc je te ce que
je te propose c'est quand c'est une
petite pause de 5 minutes est-ce que tu
pourras nourrir la partie Dali resa
qu'on regarde vite fait la position
d'Ali resa
et voilà on se retrouve avec vous mais
on se retrouve d'ici 5 petites minutes
pour pour parler un petit peu de notre
champion notre héros le héros
faut que je remette les chéquiers je le
rechangerai après d'accord allez on fait
un petit break et on revient à les
raisins en difficulté sur
dans cette partie on vous en dit plus
dans 5 petites minutes je laisse comme
ça je vous laisse la partie des raisins
en pour la pause allez je pense que
c'est pas mal
je vais partir juste
à faire pour
préparer le match ouais
et voilà je vous laisse comme ça
quand on est pas prend du temps on n'a
rien à faire pendant les postes alors si
oui il a il a le noir quand même là
c'est pas la caméra je suis désolé
sachez que firou elle est noir
on changera éviter le procès Stéphane
s'il te plaît on a pas les droits
alors cavalier 5 apparemment elle est
quand même
ça fait mal ça vas-y on va montrer vite
fait que 5 a l'air très fort parce que
et sur F6 maintenant qui est sur le
couple et 3 cliquez ici 5
tours 5 et tu vas avoir une finale très
très compliqué à protéger pour quelque
part qui est échec
c'est pas une grosse surprise c'est ah
non il change de vie quand même
[Musique]
ils veulent pas se manger des pions
la position finale un des quatre F3
partie je pense que je serai foutu là
quand même avec toi un truc comme ça
quand même les blancs des pions façon
puzzle quoi tu vois c'est quand même
ok bon je vous laisse ça on fait une
petite pause et puis je vous dis à tout
de suite
et nous sommes de retour je vous montre
les caméras aussi de Laurent et de
moi-même hop donc là on était la
position
c'est dur c'est très dur pour aller résa
bon ça va être ça va être perdu
malheureusement quasiment certainement
là complètement foutu pure moins
structure c'est cavalier sur ces 6 qui
va certainement tomber mais bon on va se
focaliser évidemment sur la grande
finale on voit Ikea moi qui est à
l'image façade Louis ping
F est-ce que je change je reviens sur le
ouais je crois sur pas trop bouger c'est
ces prochains coups et c'est vraiment
complètement foutu malheureusement je
crois que le deuxième pion alors si
tombe pas il va falloir le protéger avec
foube et 5 tours et 7 enfin un truc très
très moche
donc
ouais ça va être il y aura pas de
miracle a priori pour aller raisin
malheureusement il faudra qu'il y a
s'impose absolument contre mvl et un
éventuel je crois que ça joue les
tailles break si il y a des execos en
particulier alors en cas de en cas de
départage je peux vous montrer les
balances qu'on a mais moi je fais du
grand chef
ici aussi les départages sont très
marrants on verra bon moi je pense qu'on
en aura pas des partages il faut bien
gothams quand même gagner avant mais en
cas de départage ouais c'est très drôle
c'est The Last Man Standing
voilà faut battre faut battre maca il
faut que tout le monde tout le monde
toute l'équipe se battue on va commencer
avec 4 contre 4 en 3 + 2 et ensuite le
SMIC éliminé était des vins sort et ce
qui reste joue contre le numéro 3 de
l'équipe adverse et ainsi de suite
ok ça va être moi ça va être intéressant
à suivre on a les mêmes propos qu'hier
bon logique logique tellement les deux
équipes ont fait des des gros gros
matchs donc
[Musique]
clairement
son studio habituel
certainement on va le voir comment c'est
face à lui ping bah peut-être le point
faible de cette équipe chinoise donc ça
paraît déséquilibré sur le papier au
deuxième
aussi très équilibré cette petite
avantage forridov quand même et le
dernier bon très déséquilibré en faveur
des Chinois avec aloha qui a souffert
hier
donc c'est ton jamais bon à 2300 et
l'eau elle a enfin d'ailleurs elle a pas
1300 elle a 2100 mais elle avait 2200 et
quelques un moment donné enfin il y a
deux mois et elle a fait trois parties
et franchement son résultat un demi sur
trois donc une moyenne élo a quasiment
2600 à l'eau c'est plutôt positif
allons-y à l'instant je vous a grandir
un tout petit peu la
le truc là
les chéquier avec
voilà
est-ce que je mets un petit peu plus
grand aussi pour ceux qui regarderaient
depuis leur
leur canapé avec la grande télé hop vous
avez un très très grand rien que pour
vous
et on est bon on a qu'à moi qui se lève
pendant le parti tranquille des quatre
des cinq
c'est marrant parce que il est pas là et
je le vois et ça va jouer
une partie prendre une bouteille d'eau
c'est possible je connais le nargman
mais bon sur sur Cranves qu'il avait un
petit peu la remettre
solide je choisis par Louis ping qui
serait évidemment très content avec une
nulle parce que normalement on doit
jouer avec ces 5 quand même ici avec
enfin A6 A4 C5 on fait dans le main avec
les Noirs mais c'est vrai qu'après il y
aura puis on prend puis on prend ses
cinq qui peut donner des finales très
très égal
je sais pas ce que bon je suis curieux
de voir ce qu'il va faire d'ailleurs
pour essayer de garder des pièces sur
l'échiquier juste de changer
le petit
tour grande finale grande finale
tout simplement
c'est la finale
et c'est pas bien
je mette je change la police
je comprends pas
ok allez
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a fait moi je suis
très très curieux de voir
ça
je pense que
qu'est-ce qui se passe
j'ai l'impression qu'il a l'air de
bugger
quand tu vois la tête de Nakamura ouais
je crois qu'il a un problème parce que
il serait bon de réfléchir au cinquième
coup non non
on sent que il est pas chez lui donc
peut-être en stable
il y a un délai on voit qu'il y a un
délai quand même entre entre la caméra
et entre ce qui fait
il a pas l'air content je pense qu'il
fait
on a l'impression qu'il est en train de
décrire sur son téléphone là
alors c'est ça ok pourquoi pas petit
rock ça retombé dans un candidat accepté
une variante pas très marrante pour les
noirs
pour les blancs comment on joue ici
je prends un F6 si tu veux essayer de
faire quelque chose tu dois prendre de
la dame
A4 B4
bon ça reste chaud
donc c'est largement jouable pour les
OK
ici
j'aime pas trop parce que
vaut mieux forcer les choses quand on a
ce genre de stratégie
parce que là il reste quand même
beaucoup de pièces sur échiquier alors
effectivement il est très solide mais
c'est mieux de forcer
qu'est-ce qu'il peut faire fou B2 à
l'air tellement tellement normal
après on peut envisager qu'il y ait des
quatre fouf 3 alors il fait à 4 pour
essayer de jouer
tu prends en C3 c'est un peu dangereux
quand même sont faibles c'est pas trop
ce qu'on veut
peut-être qu'il fait ça mieux que moi
alors il a eu une déco d'après human le
type France ok donc ouais mais ça va
être chaud si Naka est déconnecté
si la connexion n'est pas avec lui parce
que c'est quand même le gros buteur de
l'équipe voilà clairement c'est pas
grand chose ah oui non non bien sûr ah
bah on l'a vu
trois fois
qui ont fait trois sur trois tous les
deux et Naka qui a fait que entre
guillemets que hein
deux points et demi sur trois et après
donc il donne
quand même
comme toujours qui arrive à trouver une
solution est-ce qu'on fait à prouver ça
qu'il faut 3 ensuite
ca va les prendre est-ce que c'est
possible qu'elle va les prendre il faut
attendre
pour toujours essayer de viser un peu
ces cases bon évidemment tu donnes
kayss5
x 3 qui est C5
et léger c'est pas trop là où je sais
pas mettre la dame même ces quatre
on peut se retrouver avec un pion de
moins dans ces histoires faut faire
attention
qui peut être un jour une cible donc
puis on prend intéressant il a mangé du
cavaliers il y a ok
attention
n'a pas buggé c'est pour ça qu'il était
pas content donc c'est la plateforme
peut-être qui a ça c'est arrivé à Maxime
pendant le champions
ça arrive au plus malchanceux comme
votre service un de vos serviteurs qui a
pas été à Paris à une ronde je sais pas
content ah ouais non c'est clair
après c'était pas un problème d'intérêt
c'était un problème d'inactivité ou une
sorte du tournoi
qui est un peu dommage quand même bon
après je comprends c'est vrai que ça
évite des mauvais des mauvais cas dans
les tournois ou les gens en fait partent
et donc ils sont à Paris pour rien
et là un petit coup de fou pour F6 on
fait quoi sur
[Rires]
comme ça je saigne pas
en fait voilà sur
[Musique]
je prends qui peut être intéressant pour
contrôler les cases et qu'elles essaient
qui attaquent là et la structure va être
assez mauvaise et surtout D8
je prends je prends je tourne un truc
pour faire évidemment j'ai pas de
grosses ambitions
[Musique]
donc ça reste ça reste égal mais
bon les pièces sont vivantes c'est vrai
que pour en revenir à cette histoire de
déconnexion effectivement on l'a pas vu
déconnecter du zoom ce qui était ce qui
est étrange si il est déconnecté de la
partie d'ailleurs il est même pas la
guerre
[Musique]
des léger souci
d'internet c'est que ça arrive parfois
alors pour 8 maintenant menace vraiment
5 il fait dame 5
dame 5 OK
mais beaucoup de pièces donc beaucoup de
pièces qui peuvent arriver
est-ce que tu veux qu'on fasse un petit
tour rapidement voir un peu ce que font
je sais pas ce qu'on voit derrière la
caméra ouais allons-y soyez qu'on te
fait
moi je peux vous le montrer
il est là mon boîtier l'air est très
riche
grâce à
c'est contre
cette partie face à Souilly
auteur d'un d'un tournoi exceptionnel
d'ailleurs hier encore des parties assez
incroyable
trois demi sur quatre avec la grande
manière comme on dit et là c'est une
quête cavalier
tu vois petite escarmouche tactique
mais on va récupérer cavaler prendre les
quatre
je crois que c'est pas très bon pour les
c'est censé être très bon pour les noirs
je sais pas plus pourquoi peut-être vous
deux tout simplement ici un peu
attention à qui j'ai 4
et 4 et peut-être une menace pour les
noirs
[Musique]
j'attaque le cadre deux fois et sur air
froid il le dessin qui peut arriver
et il fait fouder deux du coup donc sur
Full français 3 fous prends ces trois
dame prend le 4 le montrer en se venge
sur G7 à la fin des champs
donc là je vais faire ça ça et bon
je suis beaucoup beaucoup mieux là et
les trous sont case noir en plus partout
ok donc petit rock a été joué solide
donc là
parce que maintenant si grand rock
est-ce que j'ai pas fou français 3 c'est
la question
quand même et ça fait penser
le Gambie du centre c'est genre E4 5d4
tu as des lignes un peu dans ce style là
et tout mais
même si bon
mais même faut prendre cette finale là
pas forcément rêver pour le noir il y a
un pion de plus mais bon
c'est censé ici être quand même pas mal
pour les pour les blancs
j'aurais bien aimé je pourrais faire toi
aussi ok F3
aussi on va partir comme ça un peu comme
l'attaque anglaise
et noir aussi
c'est vrai que
est-ce que c'est bizarre alors
ce qu'on nous dit dans le chat c'est le
bleu il a raison on fait aussi
ils ont une agence ensemble
cela
ça nous permet de faire un petit tour
est-ce que ils ont décidé de réunir les
joueurs ça serait un peu bah écoute on
va aller voir si tu veux la Juventus
contre
[Musique]
je vais vous mettre les caméras donc
vous qui doivent faire son mur un peu
rose là
dans l'hôtel
ah non mais ils auraient pu réunir les
joueurs d'une mamie équipe oui ça aurait
pu et après c'est qui le dernier c'était
il habite où ça y est
je crois qu'il a déménagé en Espagne ça
a des joueurs russes qui a décidé de
partir il me semble que tu as raison
en général en Espagne en Allemagne
marrant il y a un pays au milieu de
l'Espagne et l'Allemagne hier hier
il était pas au même endroit et Nakamura
il a été chez lui hier donc je pense pas
qu'ils ont déménagé en trière
aujourd'hui surtout qu'il y a rien
donc c'est assez étrange toi c'est une
coïncidence que les murs se ressemblent
donc ça va mais il y a la télé aussi
enfin c'est ça fait plusieurs petits
fait voir tu en as rien chéquier tu en
as acheté je peux vous montrer donc là
la partie bon c'est une sorte italienne
ou d'espagnol c'est standard cette
position si je vous mets la partie de
aloha qui a des blancs ici
je vais vous mettre
contre
elle je pense qu'elle est pas l'hôtel
enfin en fait
c'est pas le mur blanc c'est pas c'est
pas pareil donc
je crois qu'il y a des affinités qui se
sont créés peut-être
c'est pas mal c'est pareil
c'est une vraie équipe maintenant c'est
une vraie équipe
est-ce qu'on irait pas revoir le
streamer américain quand même en
priorité
et bien le streamer américain qu'est-ce
qu'il y a pas content
il y a une pièce comment on fait alors
il fait des petits coups
et Naka qui améliore sa position
ce qui nous a proposé le joueur et là
c'est incroyable il s'est mis dans le
cahier des trois échecs maintenant
cavalier F5 admettons n'importe où juste
pour montrer l'idée pour prendre des un
tu prends de ce que tu veux prendre un
tour je reprends la tourte on reprend
qu'il est trop échec ramasse le fou B2
quel enfer il joue au F2 il se met dans
le truc et je pense qu'il y a plein de
gens qui se disent que comme tu joues
contre Naka
en fait il se mette une pression parce
que c'est Naka c'est pareil
le fait de savoir ce que je suis sûr à
100% que Louis pink s'il avait le
contenu
parce que
il aurait pas fait une partie comme ça
ça c'est sûr et là il est hyper vraiment
la pièce parce que là c'est un peu
ridicule en fait à la manière à laquelle
a fait dans le tournoi et ça c'est pas
normal enfin
il avait une mauvaise partie ça faut le
dire hein après ça arrive on n'est pas
tout le temps tout le temps au top mais
parti c'est pas terrible genre moi je
suis pas content de la faire alors lui
qui est plus fort que moi j'imagine
qu'il est qu'il est pas content
parce que perdre ok enfin
tu as le droit de perdre mais il y a des
médias il y a des manières et celle-là
c'est vrai que c'est facile quoi c'est
vraiment
il a perdu un peu tout seul quoi c'est
une tactique enfant dans enfantine
une 35 pour Lou yping il peut avoir deux
heures à la pendule
l'autre l'autre
on s'est arrêté à peu près là
F4 G5 et là ça part dans tous les sens
un clouage le fou qui défendu je peux
juste être fougée d'eux ici
je vois pas j'ai pas la règle c'est
jouer
et deux de 10 simplement pour 8 il y a
pas d'âme des 4 là
je te pose une question quand même
j'arrive pas à calculer c'est compliqué
à calculer
si je prends là tu manges ça a l'air
d'aller en fait
[Musique]
le fou peut-être éventuellement des fous
F6 qui peuvent arriver
si possible le F6 un jour peut-être
manger et avoir le vis-à-vis directement
sur moi donc c'est un beau profil actif
c'est un coup bizarre enfin je vais
plutôt essayer de faire dame de cadre ou
taureau 3 c'est un truc qui va essayer
d'attaquer les cavaliers
mais bon pourquoi pas
j'aime bien ça aussi c'était marrant
encore plus fort
le problème de fofi c'est que ça me
laisse pas grand chose non mais j'essaie
d'enlever la dame qui est un défenseur
du cavalier pour pouvoir faire ça mais
après foulard
pour la première fois
il est pas bien que
30 secondes
on dirait Sarine quoi t'inquiète j'ai le
temps ok tout ça pour ça
à 3 bon ça part avec 4
donc ça permet de garder le fou sur la
diagonale
attention je peux je peux me
introduire m'incruster en a deux
ça a l'air très bien pour freiner enfin
d'un coup
ça y est ça recommence comme hier là la
tornade la Camorra fait de CF au rideau
et si normalement il met aussi alors là
on a quand même une pièce de plus et
Naka vient de gagner sa partie
surprise
vu ce qui s'est passé vu ce qu'on a vu
qui a gagné sa partie à l'instant
oui je t'annonce
et à moins 4 d'après la donc c'est deux
pions de moins plus un pion passé enfin
bon c'est la totale pour notre petit
résumé malheureusement
qui va devoir s'employer demain contre
son compatriote mvl
apparemment d'un cas il est en vacances
à New York
mais hier il était quand même chez lui
enfin je sais pas où il habite mais hier
était quand même chez lui
[Musique]
il a gagné
encore une fois gagné ouais le début
était pas mais bon c'est toujours pareil
avec les Noirs c'est jamais facile
compte des joueurs
solides comme ça après il a fait une
très mauvaise partie
Louis ping clairement donc un partout il
reste deux parties faits très bien
contre
[Musique]
contre suit
S qui est très bien et je crois aussi
que vos kids il est il est pas mal aussi
contre
on va voir ce truc là
c'est parti à l'intéressante c'est chaud
il a de partout
ça me prend des 6
ah mais non prends ces deux rois après
ça reste toute leur opposé ça favorise
l'attaque donc les pions
pas forcément si grave même si bon si
quand même ça c'est un pion mais elle
envoie quand même que les blancs sont
mieux placés que les Noirs parce que les
Blancs ont réussi à faire un blocus sur
l'attaque des blancs enfin les Noirs
pardon on fait le lotus sont
et j'ai plus de mal à vraiment arriver
à attaquer le trajet 5 H6 H5 G6 mais
c'est moins concret là alors que les
noirs
quand même et on seconde à la pendule
pour griller seulement 11 secondes
alors faut 5
ou 5 comment on fait sur
[Musique]
Californie normalement mais c'est vrai
que les américains ils prennent l'avion
comme qui rigole
très très habitués
c'est pas nous comme nous pendant le
train plus facilement
ils sont comme nous avec le train en
fait
alors F5 ou là c'est chaud
on peut quand même faire tourner et pas
perdre la qualité on peut se clouer pour
des 8 clouages F6
il y a pas d'âme des 4 là
pardon ah non
c'est joué
il va tomber
il peut encore défendre apparemment il
pouvait manger je crois
ou un truc comme ça ouais mais ça
faisait pas envie
il a pris la tour et fini il y a même
pas de tour à champ ça sur ça
va très bon dans la forêt prend bien
entendu la ferrache prend ce serait la
grosse blague avec damage sweat
et il va abandonner dans deux coups
ok xoïe qui va faire est-ce qu'on va
est-ce que tu vas aller voir rapidement
et non il avait un pion en plus dans ces
trois qu'il a dû perdre
et bah écoute une position qui est assez
me trois ça peut mal tourner faire un
peu attention pour les blancs parce que
trois peut arriver
mais bon c'est objectivement égal quand
même cette position
peut-être qu'elle va laisser 3
d'ailleurs
à 4 est quand même mal placé mais bon
c'est pas assez évidemment ok c'est 5
jouets français 5 liquide de tour archi
nul
c'est le signe là on va voir si il joue
pour la ou pas
bon ça paraît pas très raisonnable mais
pourquoi pas
je pense que nul c'est quand même pas
mal
je vois d'accord
je vois pas trop trop là même si on perd
4 avec les Noirs c'est quand même donc
deux demi-heure et demi pour
les deux gros buteurs encore
deux gros buteurs
un d'hier
déception
ok bon c'est le numéro
c'est le numéro 3 de l'équipe contre le
numéro 2 en face
ça reste ça reste quand même pas mal
donc et puis en plus jouer une zone dans
ce tournoi franchement elle fait quand
même
très bon résultat donc ok donc 2 et demi
1 et demi
dans ce dans ce premier set les joueurs
qui ont quitté les caméras je les
enlever d'ailleurs et je vais commencer
à installer pour la deuxième partie qui
va commencer 5 minutes à peu près
ouais c'est ça bon mais ça s'annonce
ça on se bien pour les Gotham light
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire on les voyait
favoris gagne ce premier match alors
certes c'est pas une victoire c'est la
pure c'est la plus courte des victoires
mais quand même ça fait déjà un point
d'avance
on va voir mais c'est évidemment moins
augure pour les
pour les Chinois
et qui quand on a qu'à moi qui sera
opposé à Souilly dans cette deuxième
ronde avec les blancs très probablement
fais dossiers je pense qu'il va jouer je
pense qu'il s'échange des adversaires il
va il risque de jouer Louis ping
donc ça peut encore faire deux points
pour nos attaquants là
June va jouer contre aloha
et Ali resa est en train de ouais il se
bat il se bat comme il peut il donne
tout
clairement pas suffisant contre les deux
pions de plus de Bouddha Louis pin qui
est passé vraiment à côté cette partie
qui faut que je joue mieux là il faut
que je joue mieux sinon ça va ça va être
compliqué
grosse partie parce que il est pas
évident
donc
parce que c'est le numéro 3 contre le
numéro 1 et en fait
c'est pas clair quoi
contre aloi Norman
il faut du
grandes formes qui fait beaucoup de
points ça sera la peut-être le salut des
Chinois la peut-être la seule chance je
vois pas d'autres que louisping à mon
avis il est trop léger
il va se prendre trois bulles
CIF et
MVP pour compenser
on va faire une grosse journée là
on verra mais prenons sont la hauteur de
d'hier
et de toute façon elle est gothamnights
sont quand même très très favoris
l'équipe la plus forte championnat pas
se faire distancer alors pour l'instant
il y a 2 et demi 1 et demi ce qui parce
qu'en fait on a vu des trois et demi des
trucs comme ça
qui faisait au final que
beaucoup de leur match finissant en 3,7
donc là pour l'instant 2 et demi 1 et
demi ça va encore
mais attention de pas
ne pas se laisser trop distancer comme
tu le dis si bien
donc chez moi je suis prêt les joueurs
sont là ma caméra est de retour avec son
chat
et en fait après avoir vu après avoir vu
philosophe je pense pas qu'elle fait le
CF et changer d'endroit je pense qu'il
aurait mon rockeur il est comme hier je
crois
donc en Espagne je crois oui oui
il y a beaucoup de joueurs très très
forts qui habitent
je crois qu'il y a les deux sombre du
tout
c'est sûr qu'elle est chaud
il y a eu très très haut niveau d'accord
[Musique]
un peu
c'est même quand tu es même pas façon
pour la plage mais comme sur la côte
c'est quand même plus de ventes et pas
genre à Madrid par exemple tu es
vraiment le centre d'Espagne il fait
trop trop chaud en fait là au moins tu
as un peu d'air quoi
donc voilà ça va commencer
je vais vérifier mettre à jour un petit
peu tout mon petit système on a toujours
pas les parties là d'un gars qui va
jouer contre zouzi qui hier a été
complètement
bluffant c'est parti un peu ce qui va
nous faire ici qui est noir quand on a
qu'à il a pas été si inspiré que ça
contre
mais très rapidement il se fait
neutraliser et il a été mal en fait
assez vite au final
donc on va voir un petit peu
ce que ça va donner en tout cas j'ai
hâte de voir cette partie
ouais
est-ce qu'on a qu'à va déroulé alors
donc les appareils
on va avoir
Nakamura blanc
Nakamura blanc contre grille
blanc
contre
Louis hipping et maintenant c'est wave
blanc contre Rocky
blanc contre Norman Nova
je crois que c'est comme ça c'est ça
[Musique]
donc là c'est important ici donc Naka
qui favorise fais le ciel qui favori oui
elle est blanche dans cette partie il me
semble favori aussi mais bon qui est
très très bon donc faut pas se estimer
du tout et Joe and junk qui est censé
être favorite assez favori pour le coup
ouais très favorite
elle était pas mal contre VI à loi
normanova je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
mais bon elle fait apparemment en tout
cas au minimum une bonne ouverture et un
bon début de milieu de jeu
alors les joueurs qui attendent comme
nous
et ça a bougé malheureusement avec
l'abandon
de notre ami à l'IRESA il a perdu
avec Fabien de Carona
4 joueurs qui le poursuivent aller à
Richard apporte à quatre émissions
A4 sur 8 et 3 joueurs ferme la marche
dont les deux finalistes du dernier
Championnat du Monde n'est pas Ding et
le joueur local
Bogdan DH ouais hyper difficile de
lancer un gros tournoi derrière avec ta
meilleure joue du monde quand tu sors de
un mois un mois entier de de
championnats du monde sans parler de la
préparation avant le championnat du
monde et tout le stress la fatigue
accumulée lors de l'entraînements et du
match franchement
il s'est passé en fait pour les deux ils
ont tellement ils sont rendus compte
trois victoires 3 défaites de chaque
côté des tailles break EPIC
et voilà finalement le grand vainqueur
il y a un grand vainqueur tu vois je
trouve toujours un moyen de dire que
Magnus est le grand vainqueur de ce
tournoi pourquoi parce que il a 2853 ça
bouge pas et le 2 numéro 2 mondial c'est
il s'appelle Ali razafiroja il est
français mais il y a 2786,8 donc en fait
il creuse il creusent les cartes sans
rien faire avec 2779 pour une épaule
donc ça fait quasiment incroyable
très confortable il peut s'arrêter de
jouer en fait à vie et rester numéro un
mondial peut-être
être un plan de carrière je pense que
quand
on rentre un jour qui va à nouveau
peut-être qui va passer plus 2008 on
peut l'espérer en tout cas plus de 2008
d'accord mais plus de 2850
qui avait eu 28 51 il me semble alors
attends c'est marqué là je crois pas
2856,7 est à tout à fait raison Fabiano
Carona avec
2851,37 8 octobre 2014
après tu as je crois que tu as rognon
que tu as 35 son record exact
[Musique]
S qui ont passé 2008 mvl il a eu 28 19
j'ai perdu deux fois avec barbix à Paris
te concernant
j'ai pas eu deux fois le même Paris mais
le MP3
ton record hello et moi j'avais eu des
1730 j'étais persuadé 100% que tu as vu
les 1700 live tu as dû voir un live ah
c'est peut-être ça c'était
sûrs
moi je sais plus mais j'avais j'avais
parié que tu avais eu de 1730 et j'ai
perdu le pari et un mois ou deux mois
après en vrai je sais pas en live c'est
pas impossible
et j'ai reparié même Paris
et c'est là que tu vois que je suis
complètement ah barbec il profite des
de mes problèmes de de
mes problèmes de
mémoire quoi et
tu connais Barbie ça opportuniste
[Rires]
en plus dans les années 2000 même avant
l'année 2001 ouais
il avait il avait plus beaucoup plus
d'écart
que maintenant à ma venue ça va être les
poursuivants quoi et c'est là tu vois
pour Magnus ça va être compliqué elle
est tournoi parce que pour pas perdre de
points faut qu'il fasse des scores c'est
important
derrière lui soient assez haut parce que
sinon c'est l'enfer
une nulle il faut
faire perdu au minimum en fait je pense
que si tu fais deux nuits il faut gagner
une ouais c'est ça en gros quand tu fais
une quand tu
[Musique]
exagères un petit peu non je pense que
c'est trois nuls une part et un gars oui
pour être à 0 quoi ouais pour être à
zéro ah oui oui
contre Kawana
et tu le bas enfin bon c'est quand même
super résultats en fait tu as 0 quoi et
tu paieras un point un peu d'un point
dès que tu es nul toi
ils avaient pas très longtemps avant
[Musique]
il a gagné avec
mais il avait fait de nul en champion du
monde dont une où il était foutu contre
Caroline une très belle partie de
carwana qui avait raté un match enfin
une finale assez incroyable et nul au
dernier match contre Yann et pomyachi
donc c'est un peu savante fétiche alors
bonne structure le client saisissent un
peu mal placé mais évidemment pas grand
chose parce que ça reste quand même très
symétrique tout ça
[Musique]
ok alors est-ce que tu veux qu'on fasse
un petit un petit tour rapide
ça peut être de tendance si vos ridoff
mais
allez je te les mets même si il perds
pas qu'on le veille
depuis le début
ça ressemble à ça
une erreur je te prends ton fou et je
prends le centre quand même mais
évidemment ça se passe pas aussi
facilement que ça
et on le voit les Noirs ont du contrôle
sur ce pion C4 mais les Blancs jouent
vraiment l'activité
après c'est dans le style un petit peu
des deux joueurs
tout le temps
et donc un petit pion bah écoute c'est
pas grand chose et
il va attaquer en tout cas un rapide
c'est quand même un style intéressant
parce que tu peux pas forcément être
précis
et donc ok
6 je crois que c'est plus ou moins
obligé je prends les 5
ou je pense les cinq d'abord pardon je
prends les 5 d'abord
est-ce que je suis obligé de prendre
pour les blancs
pas moi est-ce qu'on recommande la vente
de carsel là sur un pétrole non je
trouve ça dur à jouer il y a pas grand
chose c'est plein de finesse
c'est compliqué c'est pas naturel ce
dame 2 dans le 7 qui a été trois non sur
un pétrole il y a plein de systèmes
beaucoup plus simple pour le joueur de
club où on peut avoir un petit avantage
pas un petit avantage d'un point de vue
objectif mais au moins une position un
peu plus simple à jouer
voilà sans se casser la tête à faire des
trucs comme dame 2 cahier des trois non
ça c'est réservé un petit peu au
professionnel
et élitiste comme variante voilà il faut
avoir une idée il faut vraiment là pour
pour les joueurs de club il faut jouer
des positions simples pour vous rendre
les positions dans lequel vous savez
bien ce qu'il faut faire et et c'est
très compliqué et c'est pas normal qu'on
peut ici
donc avec toi
non plus
donc
on aime
la mac4
dans ma cadre
comment est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on
continue le tien donc on prend rien
c'est compliqué en fait les noirs sont
actifs mais
on n'arrive pas à deviner le prochain
coup des Noirs quand même
moi je pensais je pensais ça
c'est vrai que tu gagnes du temps
effectivement c'est indéniable après
mais bon tu as toujours un problème qui
sera sur le très long terme C4 quoi
mais là il a joué à 5h alors G3 ça
menace de gagner ce cavalier quoi
alors ici il y a plusieurs moyens de
faire les choses soit on arrive à se
trouver une case en créant ce qui est
pas simple soit on a essayé
soit tu vas ouvrir la position parce que
tu as quand même l'avance de l'opin donc
il faut il faut commencer donc des F6
donc j'ai gardé 6 mais ici c'est pas
possible mais plutôt F6 dans ce cas-là
F6 après faut calculer mais
[Musique]
il y a plus de pièces complètement foutu
tout à fait ouais tout à fait on a un
raid de Blue Rift
et bienvenue donc et donc je l'ai pas vu
merci beaucoup pour le raid blue rift je
vais te faire le saut
c'est quoi le son
je connais rien moi je connais rien
twitch mais merci pour le reste mais
c'est le seul truc que je te laisse le
faire toi-même alors fais-nous
un saut
il faut que je saute alors
je connais la pétrole je m'y connais
plus en pétrole qu'en twitch et donc
alors trois des quatre qu'on a pétrole
ouais c'est pas mal si elle bleu et
le poulet de Belgique et ses trois ouais
la variante que tu donnes là avec faut 3
m des deux grands rock c'est sympa aussi
si tu préfères attaquer des quatre et le
coup un peu plus conservateur ça nous
étonne pas de ciel bleu mais c'est trois
et le coup plus agressif voilà on a un
développement facile et intéressant
donc ouais c'est une bonne ligne ça
le saut c'est ça c'est pour recommander
la chaîne de quelqu'un sur le stream
donc ouais estimation saut ça c'est il y
a que les modaux qui peuvent le faire
ok mais en tout cas
veillez leur fait qu'une bouchée là
devant il doit au film des soins un peu
bon champion olympique ça monte un peu
olympique
et là il est là il s'écroule
un peu au travers j'ai l'impression
ah ouais complètement mais on va avoir
une autre partie parce que oui va
prendre le premier
soit bien en forme là il a fait une
gomme alors tu veux voir
on n'a pas du tout vu les autres parce
que Vladimir c'est chaud ah bon moi je
pense qu'il a aucune chance
je le vois la position bon
c'est très compliqué j'aimerais pas voir
les blancs on va aller voir ça va te
plaire
[Musique]
je peux revenir un tout petit en arrière
peut-être
voir un peu il a fait grand rock ah oui
d'accord
c'est osez
le fameux pion à 3 on a vu encore hier
et c'est 5 à on ouvre toute la position
et le rat blanc qui qui est qui est pas
au mieux dans cette position tour c'est
un cavalier
et finalement les blancs qu'on réussit à
tout échanger et une tactique sur le
cavalier C6 qui va être en prise après
tous les échanges donc il y a eu un
problème
7 et là il y a quand même
il y a quand même
tu fais quoi là tours
et j'ai pas moyen de prendre quelque
chose il y a pas de truc en prise
intéressant
très marrant très original comme
construction
B4
il va pas se faire
alors
qui vont tomber
attention si tu prends cavalier prend
peut-être juste prise droit au dos ou
prise
j'ai ton C2 bah en fait il y a pas
d'échec c'est juste la seule raison
[Musique]
c'est pas grave
en fait cette pions sont forts en milieu
de jeu mais dès que les pièces séchant
en fait ça devient de grosses faiblesses
les rois il va avoir tours C2 et ton roi
F16 alors il aime bien les complications
et donc là il va falloir bouger la tour
mais donne du jeu quand même parce que
maintenant imaginons histoire de 6
bien sûr
le poulet de Belgique oui c'est ce que
j'ai raconté qu'il allait être plus fort
attention le Ding a dit qu'il allait
être plus fort que veiller à être plus
fort que lui mais il s'est trompé
visiblement
après on sait pas ce qui finit pas sans
Chine on sait pas vraiment parce que il
était très très forgeal mais c'est vrai
que
[Musique]
on sait pas ce qu'il a fait derrière
peut-être qu'il a
c'est moins investi à étudier et faire
quelque chose
il voulait arrêter les échecs
c'est pas
quand même qui prend début de la c'est
fini tout reprend vite on reprend mes
quatre il peut abandonner notre ami
chinois
quand même
et j'arrive avec ma tendance à 4
tours fermement de Tours
[Musique]
et ben
qu'est-ce qui se passe
rien du tout il arrive pas mais alors
attention
on prend les noirs
parce qu'on a joué on a joué le petit
coup avec les Blancs b2b3 qui a l'air de
rien mais en fait qui a faibli depuis
ces trois pour toujours et maintenant en
fait
c'est marrant c'est que dès que tu
bouges un plomb tu as failli ton
côté alors
c'est compliqué là tu vois la position
de la cave un point qu'elle tient un
petit peu un fil
prise
est-ce que c'est un peu osé faire des C5
j'essaie de tout cas c'est
les déclarants
et simplement
30 secondes pour le joueur chinois ça
c'est un truc dur à gérer
tu as vu le loup oui
donc on le voit un trois et demi pour
Gotham Knights avec
perdu donc je peux vous dire un petit
peu rapidement ce qui se passe chez
Johan
qui a
deux pions
ouf alors ça ça sera une surprise mais
tu tournes noir
Daloa qui est
pas je sais pas qui c'est de jouer un
peu ils sont comme ça mais
j'ai l'impression qu'elle est pas mal à
le voir contre Joan ok on va voir
l'impression que c'est pas mal du tout
gagne pas et que allo enfin sénaka même
bon snack gagne
mais pas
c'est pas mal
je vais vous
je vous ai pas voilà
actualiser le résultat
alors F5 il joue très serré alors cette
seconde avec les Noirs alors cette
seconde contre Naka il va mettre des
petites peaux de bananes un peu de
partout
donc même si la position avec si peu de
temps c'est totalement un genre contre
on peut pas prendre
tout simplement
quand tu prends ce qu'il a vu
[Musique]
c'était évident que ça allait gagner
facile en fait
c'est sûr que ça allait gagner facile
dès que ça accélère en fait
est-ce que tu connais voir jumanjoon on
va voir
qu'est-ce qui se passe ça c'est qui ça
la caméra de de Juventus elle ne marche
pas chez moi je vais voir si je peux
actualiser c'est la seule qui ne marche
pas
les les Chinois ok donc où attends mais
c'est pas des c'est pas les plus beaux
du monde les deux pions de plus mais
quand même parce qu'on a quand même
cette
B4 arrive
tu prends la mienne
c'est possible aussi hein
des pièces
tombée 6 et on ramène le roi et 3 aussi
qui gagnait tout de suite tu auras trois
forcer l'abandon 1 ok bon même là je
pense que tu peux pas faire grand-chose
non le roi arrive
5 et demi deux et demi
ça y est
on a droit au même coup de pas de 4e 7
non pour la finale ce serait ouf ce
serait ouf est-ce qu'ils ont déjà joué
un quatrième set
mais je pense qu'ils en ont peut-être
plus pas jouer que jouer
voilà c'est fini complètement tu peux
même pas te créer
j'aime pas ce qu'elle fait mais ça va
mais moi non
tu gardes le pion G6 et tu pousses là
quoi mais bon ok ça je suis gagnant tu
vas sacrifier là et tu me allez
jouer voilà tu peux même faire tout
reprendre mais bon ok
[Musique]
incroyable Alois
du monde elle s'en fout
[Rires]
c'est ouf non je sais pas moi je me
souviens moi je me souviens de ma vie
j'avais 1900 hello un feed et j'ai battu
sur Internet Michael short j'ai sauté
dans la maison mais littéralement je
sauté comme un
et ouais non mais quand tu bats du monde
quand même fait content quand même
ok bah écoute
ça veut dire une preuve de confiance de
pas être aussi bah oui je pense que
c'est presque normal en fait peut-être
et voilà bah écoute 5 et demi deux et
demi dans ce deuxième set alors un 31
dans le troisième set m'a très faim au
malt avec les Gotham Knights qui
gagneraient la prothésique donc trois
points d'avance au bout de 7 c'est quand
même beaucoup je pense enfin je suis pas
sûr qu'il y aura quand même et qu'il y a
2 sur 2 veilles
ça veut dire que les autres ils sont à
demi sur 6
on fait une petite pause avant ce
dernier set ou c'est avant dernier set
on espère un dernier set quand même
c'est moche allez petite pause moi
j'installe les trois
et puis on revient bah du 5 minutes 5
minutes tout de suite allez à tout de
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour avec Laurent la
moitié du match de cette grande finale
de la prout 2023 avec pour l'instant un
score de 5,5 à 2 et demi pour les Gotham
Knights emmenés par Nakamura
donc pour l'instant gros gros match de
la part des Gotham Knights avec
d'ailleurs notamment la grosse victoire
de Allah normanova face à la championne
du monde jumanjoon à l'instant donc
grosse performance en tout cas et elle
vient amener un petit peu ça sa pire
aussi à l'édifice parce que c'est vrai
que elle a emmenée par Nakamura
[Musique]
Nakamura
pour les Chinois pour rester dans le
match là veilli faut qu'il sorte son
eGame là qui sauve son équipe Louis pink
qui aura le redoutable privilège
d'affronter vos ridoff et normalement
oui qui est largement favori comme dans
MANOVA mais on a vu hein elle vient de
battre Juventus donc
c'est chaud partout en fait c'est ça ils
ont pas de
points facile les chinois
depuis hier on dit qu'il y a un point
faible mais bon écoute elle fait des
bons résultats donc et puis et puis
devant c'est tellement fort que là pour
le coup un trois premiers j'ai envie de
dire que
les chinois sont quasiment devant tout
le temps derrière quoi face aux trois
monstres
donc avoir en tout cas là on va voir des
des beaux petits des beaux petits duels
on voit Nakamura qui va affronter Joan
on a fait de sayev qui va affronter
aussi ouais une grosse partie à venir
ici avec vos kids qui aura les blancs
face à Louis ping et aloha qui aura
aussi des blancs face à
on va voir bon on va suivre Naka je
suppose donc plus que trois points à
marquer sur huit parties pour pour la
bottam night pour remporter la prochaine
League
donc le gotanas qui pourrait très bien
gagner le tournoi
un 7 avant la fin si il parvenait à
marquer 3 points dans le prochain set
donc quatre parties
et ben c'est terminé si Marc - 3 points
il y aura sur un quatrième set
ça serait mérité alors leur victoire
tellement ils ont été dominateurs depuis
le début mais on va voir tant que c'est
pas fait
bien
tant qu'il y a David elle laisse pas
comme on dit donc
faut quand même
[Musique]
finir finir le travail mais ils ont
l'air tellement d'accord
cette pression
et les autres sont amenés par Dakar
clairement l'important toutes les
compétitions par équipe quand on a un
leader surtout en 4 écheciers un leader
comme ça ça pousse tout le monde vers le
haut
c'est motivé tu vois
qui avalchait sur son fauteuil
qui
ouais elle a pas l'air en très grande
forme elle a zéro non elle a un demi sur
deux
et là elle lui reste
entre Norman Nova et maintenant elles
vont enchaîner Naka et fait quoi
donc pour la bonne nouvelle c'est que
vos rideau a pas l'air
alors moins fringants qui hier donc ça
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
pouvez sortir une grosse partie mais bon
ok donc Nîmes
et la ligne archi classique
ok on a ce pion isolé tout à fait
typique tout à fait ok pour les Noirs
mais sans plus ça joue aussi pour les
blancs
totalement symétrique qui favorise quand
même la nul dans ses positions ça
égalise certes mais un peu trop ouais
c'est ça
alors quoi que maintenant ça pourrait
être déjà plus agréable à jouer pour les
animaux
ou pas B4 c'est envie de faire mais
comme mon plan plus tard c'est de faire
des quatre ça ouvre quand même pas mal
les cases noires
on va faire pousser trois tours c'est un
et mettre un caméléon de 4 qui va
bloquer ce pion isolé un beau sac quand
vous avez un pion isolé il faut essayer
de bloquer ce pion
mais ensuite vous placez et attaquer ce
pion
donc là on peut prendre
deux fois donc je te rends ton isolé
mais tu as la paire de fou
ça reste quand même assez assez
raisonnable pour les Noirs il va être
plus ambitieux que ça à mon avis
aussi pour échanger les feux de case
noire
alors effectivement on espion en B4 qui
est pas forcément terrible coco il va
peut-être B5 mais on a échangé foot 15
noire et c'est quand même toujours sympa
quand l'option isolé d'échanger des
pièces l'avantage toujours le camp qui
joue contre l'option isolé parce que il
y a moins de chance d'attaque et donc
c'est vrai qu'il faut créer quelque
chose de dynamique en compensation de la
structure inférieure et là avec le foot
case noire
c'est dur d'imaginer une attaque
vraiment sérieuse menée sur le roi blanc
donc
là on pense quand même un cavaler
prendre quatre je vois pas trop puis on
prend moi non plus
logique tu dis bah tant qu'à faire si tu
veux manger un décape tu me donnes la
part de fou quoi
donc on va voir ce qu'elle a peur d'un
truc concret comme cavalier prend vous
prend puis on prend et dame B6 un truc
qui t'attaque de pions c'est vrai que
c'était obligé de faire pousser trois
c'est vrai que c'est un peu moche
c'est sûr qu'on n'est pas moins bien
avec les noirs
peut mieux probablement déjà
donc voilà peut-être qu'elle regarde ce
genre de choses
quand même il faut se respecter OK
et maintenant
qui fait à 5
que c'est confortable pour les Noirs
incroyables
si rapidement
faut voir un peu ce que je passe c'est
que la dame
il y a eu un truc normaux
à 5 ok donc là c'est plus ambitieux
c'est pour faire foudre
je le garde
à la fin
si je reste proche tu as cassé mon Roi
et le pion sera très faible il y aura
toujours du jeu
pour passer par là-bas aussi
c'est clair ça
je prends je pouvais prendre
c'est un la tête ta variante bon ouais
ouais
il y a du jeu de toute façon pour les
blancs il y a eu tout il y a eu tout
les coups là
tu as raison poulet de Belgique c'est
moi on a cage ou toujours des lignes
ultra solides avec les Noirs mais il
arrive toujours à gagner ouais c'est un
peu ça en fait il met la pression que je
vous vide quoi et tu fais douter ça
il a pas peur de jouer des positions
également ça c'est sûr en fait surtout
en blitz parce qu'il sait que
en fait c'est un magicien à chaque fois
il arrive à te poser des problèmes là où
tu penses qu'il y en a pas
et donc et puis encore une fois je pense
aussi le facteur de jouer NACA c'est
c'est automatiquement en fait ça te met
dans une situation psychologique
tu vois peut-être le fait de penser que
tu as peut-être faire nul enfin si c'est
bizarre mais
des fois ça peut être une force de de
faire un peu comment dire croire à
l'adversaire qu'il a les chances de nul
quoi enfin je sais pas comment expliquer
mais ouais d'accord mais
tout à l'heure j'ai d'ailleurs ce matin
j'ai écouté un truc donc c'était sur
insta un maître international que je
connais d'Argentine qui disait que lui
quand il est bien contre genre plus fort
il aime bien proposé nul enfin quand il
est bien ou même quand tu es égal il
aime bien proposé nul parce qu'il veut
en fait que la barre ça refuse la nuit
là bon si il accepte bah ok tant pis
mais au moins il va falloir que lui mais
s'il avait ça refuse et ben il le voit
un peu comme une sorte tu vois en fait
quand tu refuses annuler tu sens qu'il
faut prouver et faire un truc
immédiatement mais justement ça c'est
une erreur ça peut un peu accélérer si
tu veux la suite de la partie et tu
montes très souvent quand tu refuses la
nuit tu enfin c'est typique je fais
plein de gens et en fait de proposer
nuls ça peu de fertilité et lui en fait
il propose nul avec l'espoir que
l'adversaire refuse tu vois c'est très
mesquin et
bon là c'est pas pareil mais
le fait que il joue une position entre
guillemets égales entre un joueur comme
ça et ben il sait qu'il va tourner les
pièces et tu vois il commence à parler
comme à 5 ça y est il commence à jouer
puis on prend 4 stream Maximilien
qu'est-ce qui se passe
je prends un dessin
et je te demande de montrer
ce que j'ai pas tout regarder
je me lasse non seulement manger des
cartes mais en plus même tour là qui
peut être gênant sur la diagonale sur la
télé
[Musique]
j'ai pas envie de manger des cartes
quand même
une fois que je mange là il y a une
découverte
c'est bizarre c'est
il y avait quoi il y a eu ça c'est la
partie
c'est clair qu'il pousse dans cette
partie ouais tu vois encore une fois il
a deux minutes d'avance à la pendule et
ben il fait douter quoi
on tient on tient on tient la maison
mais bon effectivement c'est pas ça
parce que j'ai pas un coup de dames
avec plaisir du coup tu vas changer
OK
j'essaie de manger à deux à trois mais
peut-être que exception là peut-être que
tu as suffisamment de contrôle je crois
un truc comme ça
une grosse qualité elle défend très bien
ouais donc Dame des deux gros coup de
défense quand même faut le voir
[Musique]
comme ça avec peu de temps la pendule
qu'on a qu'à après tu peux pas trop
défendre quand même il s'est perdu
mais bon c'est vrai que
belle idée de défense clairement très
belle salut à toi Maxime il reste pas
merci c'est gentil en tout cas merci
pour les commentaires merci à toi
c'est pas comme Yumi par exemple un Yuma
qui qui dit même pas
bonjour non plus
[Musique]
comme ça mais bon
un autre garçon
d'à côté
j'aime beaucoup la peau
4 et quoi et puis on prend puis on prend
ok dame prend des quatre
on va faire roi champs maintenant pas
d'un F2 parce que d'un F2 il y a demain
à 3 donc on va éviter
roche va être très certainement jouer
prochain va être joué
très dommage d'avoir aussi bien défendu
pour donner un pur en même temps
voilà
comment tu fais pour protéger
pas de coup naturel pour défendre le
pion et maintenant il faut que j'arrive
à défendre
c'est pas facile même pour essayer de
faire un truc avec les Noirs j'ai 5 moi
je pensais mais j'ai 5 qui a
joué dans ma fie après madame
prochain coup je fais H3 avec les Blancs
et je joue après avec Madame activer
et moi j'ai pas le temps de passer un
truc comme ça il y a toujours de mettre
du couloir aussi et la dame qui peut
revenir à facilement en défense
va me trois j'empêche d'un mec et après
je regarde je garde la pression et sur
H3 aussi mais il faut prendre je crois
c'est ça il est malin
[Rires]
il te rend fou quoi en fait il te rend
fou
il a compris que H3 était le prochain
coup hop on pêche 3
j'arrive en retard à une partie
j'arrive pas à refaire une partie
si j'arrive en retard à la prochaine en
tout cas la prochaine tu seras à l'heure
à la prochaine [__] je serai là une
demi-heure avant
à regarder
les appareils
ou pas
à la prochaine je serai là mais après je
suis pas je suis pas trop en retard
généralement partie j'aime pas trop quoi
être en retard j'aime bien arriver un
tout petit peu en avance
j'aime pas trop être les cadences sont
courtes là maintenant
donc tu peux c'est des trucs on peut
regretter à prendre à une autre
alors H3 ça a été joué quand même un fou
prendre un H3 il doit y avoir une astuce
parce que sinon
je repars
il fait la tête de
couloir
ça c'est pas l'entrée sur la pour le
match du couloir peut-être dame bien
mais au pire des cas je fais pousser
vite
de façon en fait même si elle est fendue
donc je vais même B2 par exemple en fait
je sais pas trop comment tu comptes
faire
j'ai ça j'ai plein de coups qui peuvent
défendre de pions tout en gardant le
contact
sur le F3 en cas de prise H3 je prendrai
le F3
et
ouais je sais pas je comprends pas
l'idée non plus
il y a des dossiers là j'ai joué en fait
une seule fois je crois en compagnie de
de Maximilien d'Allemagne en équipe
et cette partie là
je suis arrivé en retard ah oui ah oui
bah oui je me souviens oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais je trouvais
pas la salle
vous trouvez pas la salle de jeux
dans un endroit tu sais c'est le club
mais en fait si tu veux moi je suis
rentré c'était en Belgique pour faire de
ma vie que je joue en Belgique et je
suis rentré j'ai eu le temps d'échec et
j'avais une salle avec un pare-che club
d'échec je suis rentré et je dis bah je
vais être par là quoi tu vois je ne sais
personne et en fait j'ai attendu
longtemps ici et en fait je veux pas ici
je suis dans une autre salle qui était
au bout de l'autre bout de enfin c'était
assez loin quoi ça s'appelle le
poulailler voilà non non justement
il y avait un bar pas loin
et non non j'étais je te viens mais du
coup je suis arrivé un petit peu en
retard mais de quoi de une minute même
pas en fait j'ai demandé j'ai dit moi je
suis où tu es dans l'autre salle je sais
pas où c'était mais voilà mais oui mais
sinon je suis pas en retard je suis
vraiment je suis en retard
j'aime pas trop être en retard pour une
partie de chaque
j'aime pas trop
et il rase un Furon
il y a un pion donne des 6 G6 ou dame D6
on se fait une petite case alors
laquelle je sais pas exactement j'ai 6
ça a l'air pas mal parce que
paraît bien contrôlé non elle fait des
six jouer avec le petit mais c'est un
peu de moi
elle a vu non elle a pas vu elle a pas
vu hein
malheureusement elle va souffrir là bah
en plus maca en défense c'est c'est un
mec qui blender pas quoi enfin tu le
vois très rarement en fait ne pas gagner
une position qui est gagnante quoi enfin
techniquement il est quand même il est
quand même un rasoir
et
grosse confiance en un accord dans cette
partie
en plus le temps là ils ont deux minutes
chacun et
là il est il est extrêmement fort
donc
pas mal est-ce que tu veux faire un
petit tour rapide avant de avant
ou pas ou alors là
c'est une belle partie ouais
il a l'air de la tête
[Musique]
qui est pas mal qui a le contrôle total
des colonnes
pour VI ouais non c'est
un cauchemar sans la fin là est-ce que
vos rideaux fait le boulot aussi contre
le hipping C4 on voit bien l'idée de
tomber 5 tours des deux il veut vraiment
taper de partout elle fait donc
il aura fait un il aura fait un tournoi
monstrueux et c'est même pas que ce
match là c'est tout tout le temps en
fait il a été monstrueux rapidement un
tour sur sur vos guidov ouais faut qu'il
offre qui a des blancs ici
partout il y a une minute à la pendule
pour les Noirs
déjà pour commencer je pense que le
match va s'arrêter là en fait c'est
possible si le hipping gagne qui fait
dehors si Naka aussi gagnante c'est la 2
points et j'ai pas encore vu
mais c'est vrai qu'en pratique il est
quand même en pratique il va mettre la
pression quoi
et là quand même bien il arkhame très
bien ici votre offre
peut-être juste peut-être voir dernière
fois la partie de de
Alloin là on l'a pas on l'a pas vu
contre juillet
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle est pas inquiète
la jauge
parce que je la colonne ouvertes
on prend
je ne sais pas
le problème B4 pour créer du contre-jour
ok il faut encore gagner c'est pas
simple encore
c'est pas le même c'est pas le nom hier
il a une moyenne une moyenne de coût
de 25 coups par partie et là aujourd'hui
il y a un peu moins impressionnant
en fait aussi F qui a gagné c'est c'est
officiel c'est fait
pour apporter le point décisif notre ami
voilà il va lui gratter des 6
ok
5 est terminé
mais il est trop fort
il est trop fort
et bien
ça va faire cette nuit
si vous gagnez
plus
deux pions de plus
et pas content encore
il est pas français
j'ai 4 c'est juste perdant on met un
petit fou là et on va réussir à screen
passé
trop facile
bon mais bon c'est terminé
on va voir
si vous qui doivent gagnent je vous mets
les caméras Nakamura avec sa petite tête
là il danse ça y est
OK
qui a non seulement une position
douteuse mais 5 secondes à la pendule
c'est que tout il y a un peu plus
ah c'est vrai
le compte est bon
il y a de quoi sans tous ces semer pour
le bien
semer que sur ça
c'est pour dire
ouais si vous kids gagnent cette partie
et ben le match sera terminé et la
prochaine six sera terminée
tu as une balade dessus ils ont un point
à faire derrière
quand tu vois les deux fusées qu'on a
devant
et même derrière c'est c'est très fort
bon c'est pas encore terminé mais c'est
vrai que
[Musique]
c'est vrai que vos kids il est tellement
en fait ça c'est la partie qui t'aiment
bien quoi tu vois il envoie tout et
puis avec le temps de notre ami Louis
ping tout le monde l'aime bien cette
position
ou ton projet de
attention ton projet cap raté par vous
qui offre
et là peut-être la remontada attention
menace ton jeu à part de là
c'est trop tôt mais attention attention
c'est pas terminé
quand même c'est ouf la autant alors
attention c'est pas c'est pas fini
encore voilà
voilà c'est pas compliqué
il y a plus en 4 en l'air il y a fou
c'est ce qui va arriver aussi
tomber vite tomber ouh là là c'est c'est
obligé pousser deux ah j'ai fou au 4
tout le temps
tu veux pas
voilà que c'est chaud quand même avec si
peu de temps c'est hyper dur
mais les Noirs ont réussi à
avoir une position qui est maintenant
totalement joueur
entre elles on fait des menaces sur
casse blanche
échec croisé 6
il y a un tour en prise mais j'ai la
tour reprise ici minimum tour des deux
ça se passe bien
alors que je vois que oui
mais quelle gaffe
ça a perdu fou G4 et bien cette partie
sûrement de loup qui va permettre à son
équipe de avoir un quatrième set parce
que qui a gagné aussi
donc quatrième set intéressant la
boulette alors là c'est hyper hyper de
match
mais ça paraît
il pourra s'en vouloir
franchement énorme défense de Louis ping
qui était complètement foutu et Quentin
il est content ah ouais non mais tu as
vu la partie franchement bah franchement
il se bat quoi tu vois parce qu'il était
très longtemps position regarde tu
reprends G4 de trouver là enfin
franchement il a il a il a 7 secondes
et là c'est hyper compliqué la
République passer n'importe quoi
c'est n'importe quoi
mais c'est hyper dur pour les deux
joueurs ils sont rendus coups pour coup
et
c'est les noirs qui ont gagné finalement
après H3 et tu reprends G4 c'est Laura
blanc qui était trop trop faible dans
cette partie et ça finit par payer donc
donc 7 et demi à 5,5
Bordeaux dans ce dans ce match et
maintenant dans le troisième set mais
enfin le quatrième set
les l'équipe de la caméra les Gotham
Knights doivent marquer un seul point
pour gagner la compétition un match nul
les garanties d'avoir aussi au minimum
un départage
donc voilà on va voir un peu comment ça
va se passer donc aux appariement vous
les connaissez tous c'est plus enfin
c'est fort confort
numéro 2 etc je vais quand même les
installer pour les couleurs donc je vais
les mettre là quand même mais bon
possible c'est quoi le pourcentage c'est
quoi c'est dur mais bon on sait jamais
ce serait très faible c'est très très
faible alors maca blanc en plus avec les
Blancs
ouais il va pas jouer pour faire
non je vois pas pour annuler
une partie où il jouait un truc comme ça
et il a joué une partie il a tout
balancé
les pions blé dans une position de style
dragon
au lieu d'avoir un avantage simple
je sais pas si tu te souviens oui c'est
ça oui je joue pas du tout ouais ouais
il joue il joue pour
il joue pour gagner en fait ils sont ils
jouent son jeu il fait plaisir
donc NACA blanc contre
il va laisser voyer faire et il va lui
répondre
en tout cas une partie assez
intéressante parce que vous voyez c'est
un joueur qui est attaqué et là il est
en mustwin donc
les Noirs bonne chance
contre
Norman Nova donc ça c'est peut-être la
seule bonne nouvelle pour les Chinois
il aura les blancs aussi
mais masterclass je sais pas qui est tu
sais qui a gagné l'année dernière ou pas
mais Saint-Louis ils sont à des bêtises
trois victoires de proces League ah
ouais donc
je suppose la question je lui dirai ça
mais j'ai pas sorti
j'ai pas de sortie
c'est parti
vous qui doivent voilà contre Souilly et
on va avoir aussi
[Musique]
qui va avoir les blancs
contre
la loi
lui doit absolument emporter évidemment
lui il a pas le choix de toute façon
et franchement à loi elle a fait son
match déjà hein
c'est déjà
énorme tu imagines que si elle a pas
battu jouer le jeu si elle avait perdu
le score il serait quand même hyper
serré
et pourtant le score enfin le résultat
enfin
logique
donc on a kawaii allez hop on va
balancer ça
oui
on va commencer dans un instant je
regarde si ils m'ont mis ça y est ça a
été mis à jour les appariement de la fin
du dernier set alors en cas d'égalité si
jamais il y avait un égalité ce qui est
je pense
parce qu'il n'arrivera pas je suis assez
pessimiste là-dessus mais ça pourrait
éventuellement arriver et ben ici les
tailles break c'est écrit en anglais
donc mais heureusement qu'on a un
bilingue dans l'équipe avec Laurent qui
va pouvoir vous expliquer un petit peu
les règles des partages en cas d'égalité
que se passe-t-il Laurent alors c'est du
3 + 2 3 + 2 donc 2 secondes d'incrément
et ensuite ce qui se passe c'est que le
quatrième chic et je contrôle l'autre
quatrième échiquier et s'il y a un
vainqueur il joue contre le troisième de
l'autre équipe ensuite si le Reba et je
joue le deuxième et si le Robin il joue
le premier mais en tout cas tous les
joueurs de chaque équipe enfin tous les
joueurs d'une équipe doivent être
battues
donc c'est ça le c'est ça le principe le
dernier joueur reste donc ça peut être
énorme on peut avoir des départages de
folie ou à noter que c'est nul
on passe au troisième donc en fait nul
et éliminatoires pour les joueurs et
merci beaucoup à Joachim Muhamad qui
nous fait un petit raid donc je crois
que c'était ah je crois qu'il je crois
je crois qu'il était pas là en fait je
crois qu'il fait un tournoi IRL il me
semble et donc il y a des gens qui sont
sur sa chaîne lui faire un petit saut un
Joachim
alors Joachim
merci beaucoup qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
d'ailleurs au tournoi les gars j'ai vu
qu'il avait une finale avec une qualité
de plus je suis pas resté après mais
j'ai entrevue qu'il était qui avait
l'air gagnant contre son adversaire
donc nous on a on a un petit délai sur
le stream d'une minute ça c'est un
c'est imposé par cheesecom donc on a un
point décalé par rapport à vous mais
voilà en tout cas bienvenue à tous donc
là on est à dernier set de la grande
finale de la processe League entre entre
l'équipe de Nakamura et Gotham Knights
et les Shanghai Tigers de the Wailly et
donc cette et demi 4h30 le gain se fait
à 8 et demi donc plus qu'un point dans
cette quatrième set pour la Gotham
Knights et le gain enfin
la première place leur sera décerné
donc ça devrait commencer dans quelques
instants normalement il y a une pause de
peu près 5 minutes donc là je pense
qu'on va y arriver un très très bientôt
on va avoir
la partie qui va commencer donc Nakamura
qui va avoir les blancs contre
son premier match de norme il vient de
perdre il a perdu
elle est pas géniale bah écoute dommage
c'est que toi qui fait c'est où le
tournoi
ils ont un français en plus je crois
donc je pense sans toi en France
j'irai voir un peu les résultats
en tout cas bienvenue à tous ceux qui
viennent d'arriver
on est là pour le dernier set alors
effectivement les Gotham Knights sont
largement favoris c'était le 4 et demi
ils ont besoin d'un point simplement
pour arriver à 8 et demi
mais on va regarder la cas et puis on
sait jamais c'est le sport le sport ils
ont ils viennent de rater quand même une
balle de match énorme pour rideau il
avait le c'était terminé c'était 8 et
demi trois et demi on rentre à la maison
on jouait pas de 4e 7 donc attention
quand ça commence comme ça après en plus
c'était
une minute contre 10 secondes avec une
position complète c'est vraiment gagnant
mais après c'est vrai que c'est pas le
genre à trembler Naka
quand il a gagné quand tu gagnes
chaque mois qui me fixe
ah il va manger je crois
elle sait qu'à 20h
c'est l'heure de manger du coup on est
arrivé il y a 5 minutes elle m'attend
ok alors est-ce qu'on a
toujours pas
qui est impatient qui veut commencer
il y a trois
dossiers fait bien trop fort ah merci
pour le tour de Pauline
je suis désolé mais moi non plus je sais
pas où c'est
gris berger
que les
anciens comme moi connaissent des beaux
chats qui habitaient et qui était
parisien avant
je connais pas grand monde quand même je
pense que je connais de Gonfreville moi
je connais pas 16
ou pour Vendeuvre que boisé grand maître
belge très connu André Terry COV joueur
de ami alors ça donne une chance à des
joueurs de faire des normes on voit et
puis il y a déjà deux jeunes
tome de cunnières et Benjamin de Fromont
ouais puis en fait
il est plus jeune maintenant
souvent souvent ce qui se passe c'est
que c'est quand tu fais un tournoi et
ben des fois il te manque enfin il peut
te manquer des fois de nationalité des
étrangers des conditions pour faire des
membres de maître et c'est vrai quand
même que l'avantage de faire un tournoi
fermé c'est que tu es sûr que tu fais
les points et Ben et ben tu fais
c'est ça
[Musique]
j'aime pas trop
j'aime pas trop le fait que il y a tout
préparé en fait
ah d'accord
je fais beaucoup après moi j'ai pas fait
un tour à fermer mais après oui je fais
beaucoup de toi
c'est différent j'aime pas trop mais je
suis un joueur qui qui me prépare pas
tellement enfin je regarde tout le temps
et tout mais je vais tendance à vouloir
jouer
à peu près tranquille quoi sans trop de
prépa j'aime pas trop ça
non mais c'est clair le truc de
recherche
ah non je suis pas un robot ça et donc
moi je considère que j'ai un répertoire
qui est plutôt plutôt OK et que du coup
j'ai pas envie de donner la chance au
mois d'aversaire de se préparer et de tu
vois ce que je veux dire alors si je
joue contre lui sans qui est trop de
prépa je comme je considère que j'ai un
bon répertoire
et ben je me considère comme peut avoir
un avantage dans les ouvertures quand
les gens de mon niveau quoi mais ça
c'est vrai que ça serait pas bête de
mettre les appareils 3 minutes avant et
voilà on y va moi après encore une fois
c'est André est parti plus intéressantes
probablement ouais bon après le fait de
travailler c'est bien parce que tu vois
le fait de préparer ça fait quand même
partie du sucre et c'est bien mais bon
tu vois quand tu te prépares en fait tu
peux avoir à l'entraîneur derrière tu
peux avoir aussi stock fiche derrière et
tu vas jouer comme 3200 hello pendant 20
coups et en fait moi je préfère juste
jouer quoi aux échecs c'est pour ça que
je suis pas trop trop fan de trop de
prépa
voilà donc pour la fermer j'en ai fait
quelques uns j'en ai fait deux je crois
dans ma vie
pas plus
je fais
j'ai pas fait
il est pas mal notre ami veillez moi
j'aime bien les Noirs ici ouais c'est la
position
tu prends le fou tu prends le fou et
après tu rentres quelque chose comme ça
toujours ça sur la paire de fou qui
la pression sur pion assis au final qui
est quand même défendue par le fou B7
donc
moi j'aime beaucoup les j'aime beaucoup
les Noirs ici même en peut-être un
cavalier 5 par une possibilité je sais
pas j'aime bien souvent un caboles dans
ces positions avec la paire de fou
prise j'ai un bon petit centre de pions
que c'est un coup ici peut-être que j'ai
Caval les quatre et F4 qui peut arriver
d'ailleurs
je sais pas
merci escopia pour pour ton petit
message
merci merci beaucoup
ouais moi Maxime
tu peux le prendre des prépas etc il y a
des trucs mais mais moi j'aime bien le
plus un peu l'effet de surprise on joue
quoi
j'aime bien ça
après il y a des joueurs qui adorent
préparer et qui adore la fermer parce
que justement ils ont le temps et voilà
pourquoi pas
et c'est aussi pour ça que des fois
j'aime bien les tournois où il y a deux
rondes c'est où bon des fois parce que
du coup c'est fatiguant ils ont pas
forcément envie de se préparer ouais
c'est trop fatiguant et ouais je sais
mais moi j'aime bien parce que ça va
vite et que comme ça va vite et ben
la qualité des prépas et
bon voilà vous avez compris mais bon
après chaque joueur est différent moi je
préfère ça après toi tu préfères
peut-être les préparations les vrais
trucs en fait tu vois c'est le type se
prépare tu es obligé de faire la même
chose c'est pas que je comprends avec
plaisir particuliers un plaisir fou à ce
système là mais c'est comme ça
tu étais obligé de le faire
voilà c'est comme ça le truc sinon tu as
des avantages en fait
c'est ce que d'ailleurs manuscrit le
meilleur exemple pour ça il aime pas
spécialement se préparer mais on voit
quand il arrive au match championnat du
monde il est quand même pas mal préparé
voire très bien préparé
voire pas moins bien préparé que son
adversaire c'est clair en général dans
ces matchs a été comme ça et donc
et donc voilà il aime pas
particulièrement ça mais tu es obligé de
le faire si tu veux pas avoir de
solution
puis en plus même pour pour varier un
peu telle ligne parce que bon quand tu
es vraiment très très fort tu connais
normalement beaucoup de choses tu peux
varier un petit peu les ouvertures les
variantes plus facilement mais quand un
niveau un peu moins fort et ben
généralement toujours une voire deux
lignes sur une ouverture et
c'est ton anniversaire elle est préparé
sur la Lune en spécifique et ben tu peux
avoir des soucis quoi parce que bah je
peux te trouver une idée je peux trouver
un truc ou et c'est vrai que
[Musique]
enfin je sais pas
bien il aime bien ouais non mais il y a
les joueurs qui aiment bien aussi
honnêtement avant c'était hyper marrant
dans les années
avant que les ordises soient très forts
c'était hyper marrant parce que tu es
arrivé avec ton concept le mec avec son
concept ok tu avais un truc
tu vois de de recherche de vrai travail
de recherche ou maintenant les gens
cherchent à surprendre machin jouer à
première ligne et tout ça à l'époque
vraiment tu es arrivé avec ton concept
le type arrive avec son concept à la
limite il y avait limite un accord avant
la partie tu vois c'est pas pas verbal
évidemment mais tu vois limite tu
arrives tu vas jouer ta sicilienne
l'autre va jouer au 4 il va pas changer
voilà et le celui qui avait son le
meilleur
la meilleure compréhension ou voilà
celui qui aime mieux compris le début
avait un avantage d'ouverture
est-ce que ça jouait pas avec les
ordinateurs
le fait que les ordinateurs soient
arrivés que maintenant ils soient
tellement fort que c'est impossible
maintenant ça n'existe plus la fois vous
réfutez une ligne d'ordi c'est
impossible ça n'existe pas puis
maintenant à l'époque existait encore
maintenant c'est fini
mais maintenant facile travail de
recherche
[Musique]
YouTube
tu as plein de bouquins tu as stock fish
en fait en trois clics tu peux avoir
accès à une tonne d'information que tu
avais pas à l'époque en tout cas enfin
c'est hyper facile et
enfin voilà quoi l'autre jour c'est
marrant parce que je parlais je suis au
téléphone avec une barbec si je le
raconter à ton âge j'avais joué et on
parlait de cette fameuse scandinave
et donc on parlait de lui que j'avais
joué et lui il me dit ouais mais au pire
tu es un sac est pas mal et en fait
c'est une ligne ouh là là il avait pris
mauvais temps
incroyable Naka qui attends
qui a une qualité de moi quand même il y
a un pion
attention attention
il va falloir pas trembler derrière
non non
c'était 7 + 2 quand même 7 + 3 donc
c'était Blitz tu vois mais rapide
il y a que les Espagnols pour faire des
carences comme ça
ok ridicule ouais mais en fait
bizarre et on parlait de parler d'une
ligne avec il y a un cavalier 5 F4 qui
est jouable sur une certaine ligne et il
disait qu'à l'époque ça mauvaise
réputation mais maintenant c'est la
réputation
c'est une ligne ou à l'époque lui il m'a
dit un moment je savais pas mais il m'a
dit à l'époque c'était mauvaise
réputation et quand tu mets l'ordinateur
tu as plus de
maintenant tu avant tu le sais pas tu
travailles de recherche par toi-même
maintenant tu mets leur dit tu mets
l'ordi tu vérifies et c'est vrai que
c'est chaud quoi
le gars
de 2000 où j'ai justement j'ai joué ma
prépa et il leur dit c'était trompé j'ai
perdu elle m'a réfuté sur échiquier
bravo tu vois c'est fort
ou le Morandi était pas très fort c'est
tout et j'ai pas une des variantes
possibles et j'ai pensé que ça allait
mais en fait ça allait pas
mais voilà ça c'était c'était quand même
c'est impressionnant et elle connaissait
pas elle a refait le même quoi
ouais non elle arrive
oh super partie modèle
qui nous regardait pas trop evelles
d'origine c'est vrai
c'est vrai que lui il se il se garde
évidemment
il garde la tête fraîche
et donc après ça fait que bah il y a pas
que ça mais ça le fait bien jouer aussi
parce que effectivement quand on est de
ce que tu disais la prépa pendant les
tournois aussi c'est dangereux
parce que le logiciel à force de
regarder des lignes de logiciel on
oublie de réfléchir par soi-même c'est
pour ça que nous on fait alors déjà on a
la jauge c'est un peu trop mais bon
c'est pour vous permettre de Suisse
c'est quand même du rapide mais c'est
vrai qu'on a pas une d'ordi et ça nous
permet de garder
un minimum de forme je parle pour moi
pas pour toi Stéphane
non non mais pour garder un minimum de
forme moi je pense que c'est important
parce que sinon ça serait à lire des
lignes d'ordi toute la journée
et en plus se préparer et ben ça ça
prend de l'énergie aussi de rien et une
partie ça peut durer 6 heures même des
fois même plus ça dépend
faut faire attention
il est pas l'air très content
je sais pas mais lui il a pas l'air
content
ça marchera pas je pensais qu'il y avait
dame prend ici mais en fait ça va en
plus défendre le fou
il a mangé 4 d'abord
avec ce que j'ai pas fou des quatre à la
fin
qui prend 6 justement puis on prend F7
j'ai dames 8 et je reviens
[Musique]
c'est la partie
là
force to F7 et
5 intermédiaires mais ça changerait en
fait et là je te fais chantage il faut
que tu mettes la tour devant je fais
échec t'as pas le choix et je reviens et
alors est-ce qu'on croit au forteresses
faut éviter c'est ça ce qu'il a joué
tranquille
[Musique]
qui est pas forcément une pièce très
stable bon alors là
on va voir on compte une victoire là
victoire de vie on va compter de Wailly
tu veux qu'on aille voir d'autres choses
ah ouais bah ouais là regarde F4 c'est
vachement bien
fedo qui joue contre
chaud qui joue contre Juventus
fedo qui a les blancs et c'est une
position hyper compliquée 4 minutes
chacun 3 4 5 6 3 4 5 6 on est pareil on
est Heaven deux tours trois pièces
chacun
j'ai tendance à bien vivre alors mais
c'est chaud bah là il peut se passer un
peu un peu tout et n'importe quoi ouais
alors on va voir
ok parce que on rappelle on va voir ça
parce que s'il y a une victoire de
Gotham Knight c'est terminé donc ouais
vraiment pas qu'il y en a un qui soit
complètement foutu pour le suspense qui
a les blancs qui a les Noirs
attends je suis en train de mettre les
trucs
donc les couleurs c'est bien ça
1 2 3 4 5 6 temps de plus pour vos kids
trois quatre mais il y a un roi
par rapport à hier
beaucoup moins envers aujourd'hui
[Musique]
le problème c'est qu'il y a pas tourgé
vite et le mettre du couloir
ça ouvre le CASE noir
et dû à trois ça m'aide à continuer
l'attaque j'ai quand même être obligé de
faire ah et après
c'est possible non plus hein je te
rassure
ok je fous aussi
mettre le foot en F6
le roi est quand même dans les courants
d'air là-bas il y avait des massacres ou
des choses comme ça
fais attention mais il a l'air de faire
attention à vos rides
on va voir ok pour voir donc c'est
voilà c'est fait alors
c'est bon
1 2 3
en vrai ça fait aller en compte 7 et
demi si c'est demi on compte bien pour
les Tigers et maintenant il nous reste
deux parties ben écoute si j'ouvaine
June bah
fais de cf
la partie clé enfin elle fait dossier je
te laisse choisir je sais pas
je sais pas on fait voter le chat allez
chat
le premier qui répond dans notre chat le
premier qui répond bah oui on peut pas
faire là ça il reste trois minutes
chacun
en attendant on va voir
en réel oui moi je l'ai vu déjà non je
l'ai pas vu si je l'ai vu
cette partie entre fedoc et laquelle on
va voir
comme tu veux allez pour l'instant avant
que quelqu'un dans le chat
se manifeste
ça c'est
il joue contre
trois quatre cinq on a un délai avec le
chat on a une minute de retard enfin de
délai donc à chaque fois c'est quoi je
vais je vais mettre dans le chat
tu vas pas te le premier en plus ton
message il va apparaître dans une minute
et voilà tu es le premier
nous on est en
et en plus regarde regarde le voleur
qui demande de parti
[Musique]
mais le chat il est en direct
ok ok oui je comprends
alors dans F3 moi ça va quand même pas
mal pour les Noirs cette partie
oui
j'ai beaucoup j'ai joué pas mal de fois
effectivement
à l'époque on avait le tournoi le
hamburger qui est toujours à Nice et du
coup ben je raconterai beaucoup de stars
en fait si tu veux un accueil il a
jamais joué
avant qu'il soit très fort mais j'ai vu
Carlsen j'ai vu tout le monde après le
quartier je l'ai revu dans d'autres
tournois
je l'avais juste l'avais vu à
aux Olympiades qui tu devais y être
d'ailleurs à Dresde
donc effectivement
tu as choisi j'ai raté une olympique
mais sur les
11 dernières mais donc il y a des
chances que je sois et Naka je vais nul
mais il était c'était 130 2006 on est où
quand ça c'est possible alors je suis
maintenant
mais je pensais qu'il y avait
répétitions
qui va donner la victoire
à l'équipe des Gotham Knights il avait
enlevé à la partie précédente
la Camargue n'a qu'à moi voulait
tracteurs à la base de toi là
[Musique]
il y a de la 4 échecs là
peut-être qu'il a confiance
et abandons abandon de xoli pour cette
partie qui donne la victoire 8 et demi
donne la victoire au Gotham Knight dans
ce dans ce cette projectile 2023 donc
maintenant on va aller voir la partie
que vous voulez voir absolument tout à
l'heure c'était la partie 2 jours et
June contre fedos
F7 on gagne trop de matériels qui prend
à prendre la D6 sur X 7e B6 c'est
horrible ouais victoire de ouais très
impressionnant impressionnant fait
danseriev dans cette projectile contre
normanovar
oups
et donc voilà
et c'est terminé avec une victoire de
Louis hipping et du coup ça nous fait
terminer ce match avec
9 et demi à 6 et demi donc bon
il y a eu un gros raté quand même de vos
qui d'oeufs dans ce troisième set il a
une partie complètement gagnante contre
Louis ping qui a réussi à faire une
grosse grosse défense donc voilà en tout
cas les gros champions de cette année
2023 c'est des Gotham Knights et bon je
pense que c'est pas une grosse surprise
bravo ils ont réussi à montrer à monter
une équipe formidablement compétitive
c'est ça
[Musique]
voilà de choisir le petit vorydoffre là
de le voir un petit peu se placer
un peu de réussite des joueurs très en
forme comme fait de CF bon on a qu'à on
savait qu'il allait marqué beaucoup de
points mais fais au CF clairement la
bonne pioche qui a fait un nombre de
points comme tu l'as dit même dans les
califes mais là entre aujourd'hui hier 7
sur 7 rendez-vous compte
dans leur équipe ça ramène beaucoup
beaucoup de points et ta Naka fait
d'essayev tous les deux enfin après il y
a d'autres mais les deux grosses
locomotives de cette équipe qui qui en
plus c'est toujours dans une équipe où
tu as deux grosses comme ça c'est hyper
motivant en fait c'est hyper motivant
un peu en dessous de l'ennemi simplement
3 sur 4 bon c'est pas mal mais non mais
en fait bon au final puis même en fait
quand tu joues avec des stars comme ça
tu as envie de bien faire vous avez
envie de bien faire ce que tu sais que
toi bon tu es là mais bon voilà quoi et
mais tu as même même à loi en fait hier
elle a fait nul contre contre Adiba là
elle a battu de jouer une jeune champion
du monde enfin
elle a quand même elle a quand même
participé à cette
proclamation
de titre de proches et 2023 en tout cas
bravo à eux deuxième place quand même à
mérité les Chinois qui qui était
quasiment tous inconnu enfin il avait
deux dans l'équipe qu'on connaissait pas
du tout qu'on a jamais entendu parler et
je rends hyper impressionnant que son
réveil quand même en finale deuxième et
en troisième on avait du coup les yogi
qui ont qui ont battu la mgd1 tout à
l'heure juste avant donc c'était indien
contre indien et c'est le yogi l'équipe
de Prague qui n'a pas aujourd'hui qui
qui a remporté pour cette troisième
place dans la projed League donc voilà
en tout cas merci à toi de m'avoir
bravo à bravo pour la technique parce
que c'est pas évident c'est truc de
caméra et tout se passe
aujourd'hui toujours les premiers jours
sont plus compliqués mais très très
surtout hier parce qu'en fait ils m'ont
mis un nouveau programme à utiliser et
du coup je connaissais pas du tout merci
au parti
et du coup ils m'ont donné un autre
compte pour que je puisse me connecter
pour avoir accès aux parties toutes ces
que les parties sont privées
c'était pas ma faute en fait au final je
pensais au début mais non c'était pas ma
faute donc voilà merci en tout cas à
tous d'avoir suivi l'événement merci
merci à tous merci à toi et puis je te
dis à bientôt à bientôt bon courage pour
le Top 16 si on se retrouve pas d'ici là
je sais pas si on est prévu de on va se
voir on va se voir on va se voir ok bah
écoute à bientôt pour le champions
pendant deux jours les deux premiers
jours on les fait ensemble donc on se
voit je pense que sur la chaîne ça sera
les prochains événements donc c'est le
22 donc ne ratez pas ça 22 23 et 24 25
non c'est du 23
et on couvre évidemment tous les jours
moi je fais les deux premiers avec toi
je sais pas qui fait les suivants mais
en tout cas
voilà 22 au 26 ça sera très sympa à la
cheesed Cup kit Cup du Championship tour
avec un division 1 2 français et oui Ali
resa le King